Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Mich fragen ja die ganze Zeit alle Leute, ob ich nervös bin und ja,
weiß ich auch nicht. Was fragen dich denn die Leute?
Bist du nervös?
So, wir sind super vorbereitet. Jetzt haben wir noch die Stative hier stehen.
Die müssen wir noch abnehmen. Mach du mal, aber fall nicht über dein Kabel.
Ja, genau. Versuch du mal, die Leute abzulenken.
Ja, okay. Das ist alles extrem improvisiert hier übrigens, diese Veranstaltung.
Ich weiß nicht, ob euch das schon aufgefallen ist, aber man tut ja, was man kann.
Und manchmal kann man gar nicht so viel.
Aber irgendwie funktioniert es am Ende immer. Das ist ein bisschen die Geschichte dieses Podcasts.
Das ist ja definitiv auch so ein Projekt, was einfach nur so mit,
ja, lass mal machen, zustande gekommen ist, wie das mit so vielen Podcasts so ist.
Man kennt es ja. Man kennt es ja.
Aber es hat ganz gut funktioniert. Und heute ist die 500.
Veranstaltung. Nein, das stimmt ja überhaupt nicht. Also wie man es nimmt.
Im Prinzip ist ja jede Folge wie eine Veranstaltung.
Höhepunkt.
Also wenn ich mir anschaue, was du immer für eine Veranstaltung machst bei jeder Folge.
Ja, der kann ganz schön der Terror sein. Wie auch immer.
Warum reden wir hier so komisch um den heißen Brei? Heute ist Logbuch-Netzpolitik live, die 500.
Ausgabe. Wir sind in Berlin, in der Urania und wir haben ganz,
ganz, ganz viele tolle Gäste da. Herzlich willkommen.
Schön, dass ihr da seid. Super.
Siehst du, deswegen holen wir uns Profis, damit wir mit so einem super schlechten Start.
Wie hat euch Esels Albtraum gefallen?
Oder?
Ja, da muss man gar nicht viel zu sagen. Es war grandios.
Ja, Linus, ohne Fußballtrikots.
Ohne Fußballtrikots, du wolltest es so, es wäre ganz einfach für dich gewesen.
Aber wenn ich mir angeguckt habe, wie Union gespielt hat, hätte ich das an deiner
Stelle die Wette auch nicht gemacht.
Also das war ja zum Sieg gestolpert.
Ja, naja gut, aber St. Pauli war jetzt auch nicht besser.
Ich finde schon.
Fandst du schon? Du willst doch nicht behaupten, Fußball ist ungerecht.
Nee, Fußball ist schon auch ein Teil der Gerechtigkeit, weil selbst wenn du,
mal nicht so gut kannst und wenn du es eigentlich auch nicht drauf hast,
kriegst du trotzdem nochmal was.
Und das ist auch irgendwie so ein bisschen die Umverteilung,
die hier so besungen wurde.
Da werden dann halt einfach Punkte verteilt.
Du möchtest langsam von Punkten umverteilen?
Von unten nach oben mal wieder. Oder von oben nach unten halt auch mal. Mal so, mal so.
Tim, ich möchte gerne weiter mit dir über Umverteilung sprechen.
Ja, okay, das ist eine gute Idee. Wir müssen ja heute unser Konzept vielleicht
noch kurz erläutern, was wir haben. Wir haben ja eins.
Ja, Gäste, weil wir hier völlig überwältigt und nervös rumsitzen.
Wir haben über einen heißen Brei schon viel drumherum geredet.
Ja, soll ich den ersten Gast vorstellen?
Ja, bitte, genau. Also wir haben mehrere Gäste. Drei. Ja, drei,
genau. Und es fängt an mit einem ersten Gast, dachten wir.
Ja.
Das meinst du mit Konzept.
Genau, das ist Konzept.
Dann fangen wir mal an.
Wer in Berlin wohnt, kennt den Problembezirk Grunewald.
Die soziale Struktur des Bezirks zeichnet sich durch folgende Merkmale aus.
Hoher sozioökonomischer Status, eine der wohlhabendsten Gegenden Berlins,
eine exklusive Wohngegend, der Bezirk ist bekannt für seine großen Villen,
repräsentativen Altbau und,
eine geringe Diversität. Das Quartiersmanagement Grunewald fördert Gemeinschaft
und Integration, unterstützt lokale Initiativen und bietet soziale Projekte
sowie Beratungsangebote an.
Unser erster Gast ist eine vielfältige Aktivistin und engagiert sich unter anderem dort.
Sie ist aber auch Aktivistin bei Jogida, der Jodel-Offensive gegen Idiotisierung
durch Angst und ihr könnt es euch ungefähr vorstellen,
sie ist auch eine Hälfte von Esels Albtraum, die ihr schon kennt.
Herzlich Willkommen, Elenos.
Was für eine geile Show das gerade war von euch. Hervorragend,
also wirklich begeistert.
Das ist leider nicht so.
Du bist nicht begeistert?
Doch, begeistert, aber man sieht die Leute nicht so.
Es war so dunkel.
Das stimmt.
Ja, aber das ist so meistens so, oder ist das nur bei uns so?
Unterschiedlich. Also ich wollte nur ausdrücken, dass ich euch auch gerne gesehen
hätte, aber das können wir nachher im Foyer vielleicht noch machen.
Genau. Ja, super. Ja, du bist sozusagen unsere Doppelbesetzung heute,
weil wir ja auch immer gerne mit Leuten reden, die auf ihre Art und Weise die
Gesellschaft mitprägen, auf eine private Art oder auch vielleicht auf eine öffentliche Art.
Und Linus hat es schon angesprochen, du bist ja als Aktivistin auch vielfältig
unterwegs. Das kann man so sagen.
Und wir haben gerade im, ich weiß gar nicht, seit wann wir uns kennen,
aber wir haben uns kennengelernt über die heroistische Internationale und eine
Ja, der Zwischenapplaus ist immer.
Gerechtfertigt für den.
Und ich bin auf dich gekommen als Sendungsgast, weil ich überlegt habe,
wer hält eigentlich in dieser dann doch nicht so schönen Zeit irgendwie noch
so die Stange hoch für genussvollen Protest,
für Humor, für immer neue Ideen.
Und darüber wollen wir einfach mit dir sprechen. Wir hoffen,
dass du uns heute dein Geheimnis verraten kannst, wie du auf eine und die nächste
Idee kommst und diese dann auch einfach verwirklichst.
Das ist eigentlich der Grund, warum wir dich eingeladen haben.
Sieht richtig groß aus.
Also ich kann schon mal sagen, das ist nicht mein Geheimnis,
sondern ein ganzes Netzwerk und die Stange hält man nicht alleine hoch,
sondern mit ganz vielen.
Aber was ist denn, wie würdest du dich denn selber einschätzen?
Also was bist du denn für so ein Typ? Das ist erst eine Zentnerfrage.
Naja, ich meine, wo siehst du dich in fünf Jahren?
Ich suche einen Job aktuell.
Ne, sagen wir mal so, also ich meine, so auf eine Bühne gehen,
ist ja jetzt auch erstmal schon mal nicht jedermanns Sache.
Also so eine gewisse Extrovertiertheit muss man da auf jeden Fall am Start haben.
Oder ist es bei dir nur so eine kaschierte Introvertiertheit?
Das weiß ich natürlich nicht.
Also hast du schon immer irgendwie den Wunsch gehabt, so öffentlich zu sein?
Nee, da wächst man rein. Natürlich muss man irgendwie den Wunsch haben,
irgendwie gehört werden zu wollen.
Und dann ist es einfach so ein Stück für Stück irgendwie so ein Reinwachsen, auch so eine Raumnahme.
Also weil du schon gesagt hast, es ist ja nicht jedermanns Sache.
Also ist ja auch oft so, dass auf Bühnen auch eher Typen stehen oder Typen mit Gitarre oder so.
Also nichts Gegenteil mit Gitarre, finde ich auch toll, aber also sozusagen
das ist natürlich auch so ein Wunsch von, hey komm, ich hab eigentlich Bock
irgendwie das auch mal ausprobieren und dann schleicht man sich da natürlich so ran, aber...
Ist es das Auf-der-Bühne-Sein, etwas machen, was dich motiviert?
Oder ist es eher die Veränderung, die du herbeiführen willst? Ist das aktivistische?
Ich würde das gar nicht trennen. Ich glaube, das Ding ist, dass man Bock auf etwas haben kann.
Und das dann zu verbinden mit der Message, das ist, glaube ich,
das Ding. Ich glaube, es ist schwierig, das zu trennen. Ich will jetzt auf jeden Fall auf eine Bühne.
Und dann überlege ich mir, was ich sage. Das ist ja Quatsch.
Also man hat irgendwie so den Impuls, mir fehlt hier irgendwie irgendwas,
was kommuniziert wird, im Diskurs
fehlt mir was, eine Ansicht oder einen Ansatz und dann überlegt man,
wie kann man den irgendwie vermitteln und dann gibt es tausend unterschiedliche
Varianten, wie man das machen kann und für mich macht das irgendwie am meisten
Spaß mit diesem Jodeln oder irgendeinem anderen Schabernack,
wo man doofe Perücken auf hat.
Aber, ja.
Würdest du, also ich habe manchmal, ich habe ja mit der Protestkultur so meine Probleme.
Ich finde das häufig ein bisschen zu ernst.
Ich habe häufig den Eindruck, dass man, ja, also warum soll das nicht einfach auch Spaß machen?
Und mir fehlt bei vielen Protestansätzen so ein bisschen dieser,
jetzt machen wir allen schlechten Laune, bis die Welt besser ist,
da verstehe ich den Umweg nicht.
Und trotzdem behandelt ihr ja sehr schwierige Themen und darin aber mit einem
wunderschönen Humor. Wo kommt der her?
Wie kann ich mir den aneignen? Also was brauche ich dafür?
Ähm, ich würde sagen, erstmal so von wegen Protestkultur, Protestlandschaft,
ich denke, es muss immer ein Methodenmix sein.
Oft ist, wie so oft ist Vielfalt einfach gut und ich glaube,
man könnte damit anfangen, nicht immer zu sagen, die anderen sind irgendwie döfer als einen.
Es gibt einfach so unterschiedliche Ansätze und das mit dem Humor ist einfach
der Ansatz, dass man, also was ich daran schätze, ist, dass man sozusagen beim
Machen das, wo man hin will, schon aufscheinen lässt.
Das heißt, du willst irgendwie eine solidarische Gemeinschaft,
darum musst du dich solidarisch organisieren.
Du willst irgendwie eine Gemeinschaft, wo Genuss eine Rolle spielt,
also musst du den Protest auch genussvoll machen.
Also dass es irgendwie sozusagen stimmig ist in der Methode und das ist...
Mich so an, aber ich verstehe auch, wenn andere Leute das nicht können,
das ist ja auch, was heißt können, aber sozusagen einen anderen Ansatz haben,
weil es ist natürlich auch immer irgendwo, ja,
also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es Themen gibt, wo es extrem schwer ist,
einen humorvollen Ansatz zu machen. Ich glaube, es geht öfter, als man denkt.
Also das merke ich auch, ich bin auch Sterbebegleiterin und da würde man ja
denken, da wird es gar nicht lustig, aber da wird ja auch öfter gelacht,
als man so denkt, auch auch weil es ernst ist.
Und ich glaube, das ist so die Verwechslung, dass Leute manchmal uns sehen und,
so ein bisschen skeptisch sind und...
Achso, Roland zeichnet da oben Dinge.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen asynchron.
Das ist nur, weil du was Kluges gesagt hast.
Dass Leute uns sehen und denken, die machen Scherz drüber, darum meinen sie es nicht ernst.
Aber der Punkt ist ja, weil man es so ernst nimmt, Und versucht man es sozusagen
auf so eine Art vorzubringen, weil das ja auch was Entwaffnendes hat.
Also man kann sagen, das ist ja auch, Humor ist eine Waffe oder ich würde eher
sagen, ist entwaffnend oder auch entlarvend oft.
Also das ist ja auch kein Zufall, dass KomikerInnen oft dann als erstes verboten
werden oder dass es eben Flüsterwitze gibt, weil die Leute machen immer noch
Witze, aber halt leise und wir können sie jetzt noch laut machen.
Also das ist ja irgendwie so, Humor ist ja einfach eine Art auch mit Problemen
umzugehen, eine ganz, ganz, ganz wichtige Art.
Also darum ist das so der Ansatz, aber wie gesagt, ich würde nicht sagen,
andere Ansätze sind schlechter, sondern mir macht der meisten Bock,
ja, und ich werbe dafür, aber nicht alleine, sondern mit vielen anderen.
Dann ist es quasi ein Plädoyer, schöne Sachen miteinander auf die Beine zu stellen
und dabei auch quasi schon so einen Vorgeschmack vom guten Leben zu haben.
Erzähl uns doch mal ein bisschen von diesem Quartiersmanagement Grunewald.
Wie kam es denn dazu und welches gesellschaftliche Problem wird gelöst?
Angegangen.
Auf die Agenda gesetzt.
Ja, auf die Agenda gesetzt.
Das ist ganz wichtig, dass wir das immer auf die Agenda setzen.
Verstehe.
Weil das wird ja so oft vergessen, weil man über Migration redet zum Beispiel
die ganze Zeit, aber halt nicht um die ungleiche Verteilung von Vermögen.
Also mit dem Quartiersmanagement Grunewald, da könnte ich jetzt urlang erzählen, weil das ist seit 2018.
Gibt es uns ja schon.
Und das ist auch so aus einer, nicht einer strategischen Erwägung rausgeboren,
also dass man sich trifft und überlegt, was macht man jetzt sondern das war
auch so eine Schnapsidee, lass mal was zusammen machen,
mit ein paar Bands das Kreativprekariat aus Berlin hat sich versammelt und einen
schönen Abend gehabt und dann lass mal was zusammen machen, ja am 1.
Mai aber mal nicht nach Kreuzberg, sondern Kronewald, haha so ein Blabla und
dann war aber so, ja lass das mal echt machen
und haben uns noch ein paar Leute dazugeholt, eine Gruppe gemacht wer hat da
irgendwie auch Lust Die Hedonistische Internationale war dann am Start,
hat sich eine Sektion gegründet und dann haben wir 2018 eben in diesem Villenviertel
Grunewald eine Erste-Mai-Demo gemacht.
Erste-Mai-Demos haben nicht den besten Ruf in Berlin?
Ja, genau, das war auch so die Alternative, aber man muss dazu sagen,
es war eben nicht die Idee, jetzt eine Alternative zu Kreuzberg zu machen,
unbedingt, also nicht so eine große, Sondern es war eigentlich eher so,
ja, wir haben 200 Leute angemeldet.
Und dachten, ja, wir laufen da ein bisschen rum. Haha, lustig irgendwie.
Und dann kamen aber halt 5.000.
Und die Presse, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man eine Presseerklärung überhaupt draußen
hat, aber es war halt auch für einmal total viel, es hat wie so gezündet.
Und das hat uns total überrumpelt. Erstmal, weil so viele Leute waren.
Und aber auch, wie die Leute drauf waren. Nämlich richtig gut.
Und die hatten quasi unser Story mit diesem Quartiersmanagement und mit der
aufsuchenden autonomen Sozialarbeit haben die richtig das Narrativ übernommen
und waren dann da als autonomes,
Finanzamt Wilmersdorf oder also, die hatten Schilder gemalt und das hat richtig
Bock gemacht und dann war es auch nicht schlimm, dass unser,
Lauti nur ein Teil bespielt hat.
Das war dann nicht schlimm, weil alle hatten einen guten Spaziergang und die
Polizei war natürlich auch extrem überrumpelt, denen war es richtig unangenehm.
Was dann dann zugeführt hat also die haben sich einfach verschätzt wie wir auch,
die haben euch geglaubt.
Dass da nur 200 Leute kommen?
Ja, wir haben uns ja selber geglaubt wir haben ja nicht angelogen wir dachten
halt, es wird so ein netter Tag und es war ja auch war dann halt sehr erfolgreich
und daraus ist dann so ein bisschen wie so eine Tradition geboren dass wir da
jetzt einfach jedes Jahr sogar im Corona-Jahr da waren da aber mit Autokor so nur 20 Leuten.
Wie hat denn der Problembezirk jetzt auf eure autonome Sozialarbeit und Steuerfinanzamtarbeit reagiert?
Ja, also man muss sagen, das ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Also es gab, ich glaube viele waren einfach überrascht und Überraschung ist
im Protest glaube ich immer eine sehr gute Sache, weil man erstmal überlegen
muss, ups, damit habe ich jetzt nicht gerechnet, wie finde ich das denn jetzt?
Und diese Lücke, diese paar Sekunden, wo Leute überlegen, oder Minuten oder
Tage, wie finde ich das denn jetzt?
Die sind irgendwie Gold wert für einen Protest, weil da passiert irgendwas in den Köpfen.
Und viele waren überrascht, viele waren natürlich auch total allergisch.
Das ist dann die allergische Reaktion der Bourgeoisie, die dann so,
oh Gott, sie kommen und sie wollen uns was wegnehmen und der Pöbel kommt und so.
Das ist doch ein Jokalypse im Grunewald.
Ja, und man wird natürlich, also man wurde angeschrien. Was hat man gesagt? Wir sind langweilig.
Neid kommt natürlich immer. Wir sind einfach nur super neidisch.
Wir haben noch nie was geleistet in unserem Leben. Wir haben noch nie Steuer gezahlt.
Was einfach wirklich der Oberhammer ist.
Von den Leuten ist das wirklich ein brecher Vorwurf.
Ich finde es auch sehr, sehr, sehr frech.
Und das waren zum Teil Leute, die da wohnen, aber halt natürlich auch so Ulf
Poschardt oder Schupelius oder so, die haben sich alle sehr geärgert und.
Wenn auf einmal das Paradies gestört wird, ne?
Ja, Volker Beck, fütterte neokommunistischer Wahn und also wir haben echt sehr
viele Vorwürfe auch bekommen, aber das ist ja dann auch immer ein bisschen,
und das Beste war, dass dann, also 2018 2018, alle waren überrascht.
2019 sind wir dann zur Polizei, wollten Rute anmelden und dann kam so,
ja, es gibt eine Gegendemo.
Ich so, ja.
Ja, wer denn? Es hat ein FDP-Typ hat dann tatsächlich eine Gegendemo angemeldet.
Unter dem Motto nie wieder Sozialismus.
Und festgekommen?
Leider, leider hat er dann gemerkt, dass dass das wirklich eine Panne,
also nur schlimm für ihn enden kann.
Und hat er dann zurückgezogen. Aber wir hätten uns ehrlich gesagt wahnsinnig
gefreut, wenn der Staat gebunden hätte.
Aber es war einfach schön, weil das passiert oft bei anderen Demos nicht so,
dass dann sowas kommt. Also, dass die FDP eine Demo anmeldet.
Das ist geil. Ich hatte auch kurz die Vermutung, dass es Lidos war.
Ja, ja, ja. Nee.
Oh Mann. Aber jetzt mal ein bisschen kritisch gefragt. Weil das muss sich,
glaube ich, auch jeder und jede fragen lassen.
Bewirkt es was? Also was hast du festgestellt? Ich meine, es ist lustig.
Ich meine, ich lese mir das durch, ich quartiere es mir nicht grün,
weil ich liege am Boden vor Lachen.
Es ist einfach großartig, diese ganze Herleitung, weil es einfach die Absurdität
der Realität, die ja da ist, einfach so schön wahrliegt.
Aber jetzt wissen wir auch nicht, jeder kann das so für sich nachvollziehen
oder macht sich auch nur Gedanken oder nimmt sich Zeit dafür.
Aber hast du den Eindruck, dass es jetzt entweder bei den Teilnehmern oder dem
Umfeld dieser Veranstaltung oder überhaupt des gesamten Projekts oder vielleicht
auch bei den Leuten im Grunewald etwas bewirkt.
Also es ist mehr als plakatives Auf-die-Agenda-Setzen, wie du das jetzt gesagt
hast, um überhaupt erstmal im Kampf um die Aufmerksamkeit da eine Stufe auf der Leiter zu nehmen.
Also der Tim will eigentlich wissen, wie viel Vermögen wurde jetzt schon zu euch umverteilt.
Nee, aber so was wirkt es und wenn, ja, wie wirkt es?
Also es ist halt extrem schwer messbar. Darum kann ich jetzt nicht sagen,
ja, hier, das und das haben wir schon geschafft, aber...
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube ja nicht, also ich glaube nicht an Wiedergeburt,
darum glaube ich, unsere Zeit hier auf Erden ist begrenzt und irgendwie,
ich habe mir irgendwann mal vorgenommen, nur noch Sachen zu machen,
die entweder absolut notwendig sind,
auch wenn sie keinen Spaß machen oder eben sinnvoll und was bewirken oder eben
Spaß machen und ich finde, bei diesen Aktionen, es fällt alles drei zusammen und wenn,
selbst wenn man in manchen Tagen, stelle ich mir nämlich die Frage auch und
dann denke ich, naja, war immer noch spaßig, also es ist nicht ganz verschütt und ich glaube,
dass man, ja, man kann es halt so machen, nicht messen, aber wenn man zum Beispiel 2021,
das war nach dem Corona, ich meine, da hatten wir so eine Fahrradsternfahrt gemacht,
auch noch wegen Hygienevorschriften und so, da dachte man Sternfahrt,
da waren halt über 10.000 Leute auf der Straße, mit so einem breiten Grinsen,
weil endlich was los war und weil man auf die Straße konnte und auch nochmal wirklich.
Kollektiv eine politische Meinung zum Ausdruck bringen und zwar nicht defensiv
irgendwas verteidigen oder verbissen, sondern freudvoll und ich glaube,
das ist nicht zu unterschätzen, das kann man halt nicht messen,
aber wenn diese Leute dann,
also wenn 10.000 Leute mit so einem neuen Schwung irgendwie in ihren Alltag
gehen und da politisch wirken, wo auch immer,
also vielleicht nicht in einer Steuerverhandlung, sondern im Kindergarten oder
keine Ahnung wo, also wenn politische Leute irgendwo sind,
dann wirken sie politisch und dann kannst du das nicht messen,
aber ich glaube, dass dieser Schwung oder dieses Gefühl von,
man kann was gestalten, es ist nicht alles frustrierend, es gibt Leute,
die denken wie ich, es gibt irgendwie schöne Dinge,
dass man das halt, das ist einfach irgendwie eine wichtige Sache, aber,
aber klar, also die Gesetze werden wir nicht schreiben, logisch,
man kann einfach nur immer wieder mit dem Finger darauf zeigen,
wo man hingucken sollte und.
Also ich finde, die Frage, was hat der Protest bewirkt, ist eine sehr gemeine, Tim.
Jeden Protest oder jeder Protestform kannst du die einzeln rausnehmen und sagen,
was hast du denn jetzt bewirkt.
Am Ende hast du ja schon gesagt, es muss halt was Gesamtes sein.
Es muss irgendwie auch ein Geist halt irgendwie vermittelt werden.
Und das finde ich an diesen Aktionen so schön, dass man weiß einfach,
man ist da gerade bei den richtigen Leuten, weil es einfach eine schöne Stimmung gibt.
Es gibt ja auch viele Demonstrationen, wo es keine schöne Stimmung gibt oder
auch irgendwie gerade eine relativ starke politische Bewegung in Deutschland,
die ist glaube ich auch unzufrieden, wenn man mal so hört, was die sagen,
aber die haben jetzt auch nicht irgendwie nennenswerte Ansätze,
wie sie das ändern wollen.
Die wollen einfach weiter unzufrieden sein und jetzt, keine Ahnung, AfD wählen oder sowas.
Und da finde ich es natürlich schon sehr viel schöner, diesen Wandel irgendwie
auch zeigen und leben zu können und einfach mit etwas Schönem da zu sein.
Aber es erklärt immer noch nicht, warum man dabei aufs Jodeln kommt.
Ja, das stimmt. Das ist vielleicht nicht auf den ersten Blick.
Für mich macht das total Sinn. Ich habe irgendwann mit dem Jodeln angefangen.
Ich fand es eine supergeile Sache, weil es hat natürlich ein Imageproblem,
weil die meisten Leute denken dann sofort an irgendwelchen Heimatkitsch oder
so, aber vergessen, dass es einfach eine global, also eine weltweit etablierte
Stimmtechnik ist, die es in total tausend Varianten gibt.
Ich muss auf jeden Fall aufhören, über Jodeln zu reden, weil darüber kann ich schon Stunden reden.
Wieso? Nichts da. Genau, aber...
Ich hab nicht aufgehört.
Über Jodeln zu reden, jetzt wird man über Jodeln geredet. Also ich meine, du hast ja total recht.
Ja, genau. Also es ist auf jeden Fall eine ganz große Bandbreite und es macht
einfach extrem Spaß und auch so ein bisschen süchtig und hat eben dieses Imageproblem.
Das freuen wir jetzt aus. Genau und ich habe das Gefühl, dass zum Beispiel Anarchie
hat auch ein Imageproblem, weil ganz viele Leute denken,
das ist so Gewalt und Recht des Stärkeren und so und eben nicht zärtlich und
solidarisch und keine Ahnung, herrschaftskritisch.
Und da dachte ich, okay, zwei Sachen mit so Imageproblemen, wenn man die zusammenpackt
und anarchistisch jodelt, also für mich macht das so total Sinn,
weil ich beides mag und beide sozusagen so ein Gefühl habe, was es sein kann
oder einen positiven Bezug dazu haben.
Und wenn man das aber kombiniert, entsteht einfach so viel Irritation.
Und da sind wir wieder bei diesem Überraschungsmoment. Also ich habe das Gefühl,
die Leute sind einfach so irritiert, was das jetzt soll, dass da wirklich,
Weil man es halt nicht so wegsortieren kann. Man ist nicht sofort in der Schublade drin.
Oft ist es ja so, du wirst halt bombardiert mit Eindrücken und dann weißt du,
okay, das ist eine Punkband, das ist eine ...
Und wir sind schon irgendwie so ziemlich weird.
Ihr seid der SEK-Einsatz in der Aufmerksamkeitsbegründung.
Wir kommen dann einfach reingestürmt.
Was macht denn so süchtig an Jodeln?
Das ist so geil. Also erstmal ist es also der Bruch, ganz einfach der Bruch,
weil also Jodeln ist ja quasi die Stimmtechnik, wo du zwei verschiedene Stimmqualitäten
hast, diese Register, also die,
Bauchstimme und Kopfstimme kann man sagen oder Obrus und Unteres Register und
das sind zwei getrennte Klangräume, wenn man so will, aber die sind natürlich,
gleichzeitig auch eng verknüpft und diesen Bruch dazwischen, den man,
du guckst so kritisch Ich habe meine Zwei-Stimme-Go-On Naja,
das, wie man so ruft, oder redet, und wenn du mal so ein Äffchen machst, oder so,
ja genau. Und wenn du sagst, dann hast du quasi einmal dieses Gerufene,
oh, hallo, hey, mein Bier, und dann hast du dieses Sphärische.
Und wenn du das sozusagen, diese Welten zusammenbringst, ohne sie zu trennen,
sondern zu sagen, okay, das sind zwei Sachen, die können gleichzeitig sein in meinem Körper.
Aber wie?
Also Jodeln ist das, was passiert, wenn man, wenn man, macht deinen Körper automatisch
wieder emotional sozusagen,
wenn man ihn lässt und wenn man es nicht verlernt, weil es ist natürlich schambesetzt,
diesen Bruch, also besonders in der Pubertät mit Stimmbruch und so,
wenn die Stimme so oder wenn man aufgeregt ist und das so, dann ist einem das voll peinlich.
Und darum trainiert man das ab, in klassischen Gesang trainierst du diesen Bruch auch ab,
Und ich finde diesen Bruch einfach ziemlich geil. Und den kann man kultivieren und das dann jodeln.
Muss man da viel üben, bis man das irgendwie richtig drauf hat?
Also bis man es richtig drauf hat unter Garantie. Aber ist das so an sich schwierig?
Nein. Nein, kann ich nur allen empfehlen. Wir bieten ja auch ab und zu...
Jodel-Diplom an.
Jodel-Diplom, genau. Ernsthaft?
Nein, nicht Jodel-Diplom, aber wir haben ja, wurde ja gesagt,
also wir sind ja nicht nur ein Band, sondern auch eine Gruppe,
die Jodel-Offensive gegen Idiotisierung durch Angst.
Jogida und wir sind quasi eine Jodelbande, die zu Protesten geht und da machen
wir davor natürlich immer so ein Crashkurs.
Das machen wir auch oft bei Konzerten, damit alle schnell mitsingen können,
relativ charmebefreit. Lernt man Jodeln?
Sind ja Leute, die können jetzt Jodeln. Ich nicht, aber vielleicht...
Ich würd sofort mit Jodeln. Ja? Ich glaub, ich wär ein guter Jodler.
Wir können ja was ganz kurzes machen. Genau, wir können einmal einfach machen, hey, oh, hallo,
hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo.
Ja, ja, irgendwie so.
Also ich glaube, das wäre ein bisschen zeitintensiver, aber im Prinzip macht
man natürlich Vorübungen, also wenn ihr Lust habt zu jodeln,
wir machen das manchmal bei Workshops, kann man gerne mitmachen,
aber wir machen das nicht nur so, sondern wir machen das, um auf Proteste zu
gehen und da kann ich gleich Werbung machen am 21.
September nämlich, da ist wieder Schweigemarsch für das Leben von so sehr gruseligen Leuten.
Oh, das ist so gestern. Das ist wie in Amerika, oder?
Ja, da läuft auch schon mal so eine Beatrix von Storch mit.
Schweigen, okay, das ist so der Inbegriff der Humorlosigkeit.
Ja, und das sind halt christliche FundamentalistInnen und auch auf jeden Fall
Rechte mit Kornblume am Revier und so.
Und die, also gegen das Recht auf Selbstbestimmung, die ist das,
kann man sich vorstellen mit Kreuzen und Bildern von toten Embryos,
laufen die dann durch die Stadt und schweigen.
Und wir sind natürlich auch da und wir schweigen nicht.
Also wer Lust hat, kommt gern,
checkt unsere Website und da gibt es dann Treffpunkte und dann macht das immer
sehr viel Spaß, weil man trifft sich und jodelt und man muss auch nichts können.
Man muss nur wollen.
Man muss es fühlen und zulassen.
Ja, und ich glaube, das funktioniert auch. Also ich meine, ich wollte mit meiner
Frage nach der Messbarkeit mehr so eine anekdotische Bemessung,
weil man hört ja so rein in die Community und dann kriegt man halt auch Feedback.
Ist ja bei uns bei Podcast auch so.
Wir können ja jetzt sozusagen unsere Wirkung auch nicht messen in dem Sinne.
Es ist halt eine reine anekdotische Feststellung und es kommen schon oft so private Storys.
Und ich merke immer wieder, dass wenn man so ein bisschen den Hampelmann macht
und ein bisschen so in der Öffentlichkeit ist und ein bisschen aus sich raus
geht und es manchmal auch vielleicht ein bisschen anstrengender ist,
als man das so selber gerade eigentlich für sich im Inneren so verheiratet bekommt,
wird es schon auch wertgeschätzt, dass Leute ein bisschen lauter sind.
Und ich merke schon, dass dann oft die Reaktion ist, dass Leute sich dann auch
abgeholt fühlen, auf einmal rausgehoben fühlen, vielleicht auch aus so einem privaten Loch.
Ich höre das oft so, dass Podcasts einen auch durch eine schwere Zeit begleiten.
Und ich denke, alle Leute, die so ein bisschen Öffentlichkeit wagen und jetzt
nicht unbedingt ein Top-Talent sein müssen,
sondern die einfach nur, weil sie was wagen, dann auch automatisch eine positive
Wirkung haben auf das unmittelbare Umfeld.
Und deswegen kann man eigentlich solche Aktivitäten gar nicht hoch genug einschätzen.
Ich denke, das ist die Sache immer wert.
Ja, Linus, hast du noch was? Hast du noch was?
Hast du noch was? Das ist jetzt die Gelegenheit. Du kannst noch jodeln.
Nein, das habe ich ja schon gemacht.
Ich würde mich freuen, wenn du noch eine Protestanekdote erzählen würdest,
weil es muss so viele geben.
Und dieses Verblüffungsmoment, wenn man da rausbricht, Das sind die Geschichten,
die ich am liebsten höre.
Ja, wir haben ja echt einfach so viel Unterschiedliches gemacht.
Wir haben ein Autokorso gemacht mit Fernsehgarten. Wir haben unterschiedlichste Videos gemacht.
Wir haben einen Audio-Walk gemacht.
Die einzige Sache, die wirklich gar nicht funktioniert hat, kann ich erzählen.
Ah, das ist super.
Das kann man ja auch mal sagen, weil die hat auch niemand mitgekriegt.
Jetzt kriegt sie vielleicht jemand mit.
Wir haben nämlich tatsächlich so ein Speed-Dating machen wollen am Hagenplatz,
also mit quasi so Suche-Elite-Partner-Inn-mäßig und haben uns da hingesetzt
an einem schönen Sonntag am Hagenplatz und wollten sozusagen so 101.
Wo ist der Platz? Achso, in Grunewald, Entschuldigung.
Ja, okay. Grunewald, genau.
Und das hat wirklich leider überhaupt nicht geklappt, weil wir dachten,
das wäre so schön mal in direkten Kontakt zu kommen.
Genau, ansonsten, ja, es gibt so viele Anekdoten, ich habe das schon,
Die Gegendemo habe ich ja auch schon. Ah, es gab eine selbstorganisierte Gegendemo,
genau, das war auf jeden Fall auch sehr lustig.
Vielleicht muss man noch sagen, dass wir einfach immer wieder auch die Narrative wechseln.
Wir haben jetzt über das Quartiersmanagement geredet, aber wir waren ja auch
zum Beispiel da als RWE Grunewald, als Reichtum wird enteignet Grunewald und
haben gesagt, wir müssen jetzt mal die richtige Kohle abbaggern.
Wir baggern immer die falsche Kohle ab und jetzt gehen wir mal da in dieses,
Kohleabbaugebiet Grunewald, das wird jetzt das Revier und baggern die Kohle
ab und verteilen die um und das ist zur Ausnahme immer nicht klimaschädlich.
Dann dieses Jahr waren wir als SEK da, quasi als Superenteignungskräfte und
haben eine Razzia gemacht, weil da ja auch sehr viel Finanzkriminalität ist.
Superenteignungskräfte?
Superenteignungskräfte, genau und haben da einfach sozusagen da mal alles durchgefilzt
und da war lustig, ja, das ist so eine Mini-Anekdote, vielleicht aber die,
was ich da total lustig finde und das dockt vielleicht auch anderen,
das, was du meintest mit Wirksamkeit und kriegt man das mit,
da war so, da haben wir irgendwie auch so eine lustige PM wieder,
rausgehauen, so Pressemitteilung und es ist ja nicht so, dass man das krass
bespricht, aber man sitzt da halt irgendwie in so einem Laptop und schreibt
das halt rein und am nächsten Tag steht es in der Zeitung, ist voll krass,
auch für die eigene Selbstwirksamkeit und dann hat uns jemand angeschrieben
über bei Insta und sagst so, ja,
voll lustig, wir nehmen das gerade im Deutschkurs durch.
Und so, okay, was? Ja, wir haben uns ja gerade im Deutschkurs,
haben eure PM durchgesprochen und,
besprechen da politische Sprache und das finde ich ist interessant,
weil, also klar, hast du viele Anekdoten, so am Gartenzaun, was da passiert
einfach, ganz viel irgendwie Leute, AnwohnerInnen, die sich,
gibt es eine Million Anekdoten, die kann man gar nicht fassen, aber das sind so, auch so,
unsichtbare Sachen, also wo man das Gefühl hat, man reicht wirklich,
irgendwo rein, wo man es nicht ahnt.
Das kriegen Leute mit, die es eigentlich vielleicht nicht mitkriegen würden,
einfach weil du Schülerin der 10b bist.
Scheint auf jeden Fall eine ganz coole Lehrerin oder Lehrer gewesen zu sein.
Ja, genau. Ansonsten ist es halt sehr viel. Aber ich glaube,
das Wichtigste ist nochmal ganz kurz zum Thema Humor, dass man einfach auch
über sich selber lachen kann.
Ich glaube, weil du nach einem einem Geheimrezept gefragt hast,
weil ich glaube, es gibt viele Leute, die irgendwie so Sachen lustig machen,
aber dann nicht über sich selber lachen können und das ist das Problem und das
ist auch nochmal so dieses,
Herrschaftskritische, dass du immer gegen Staat und Kapital und Patriarchat,
was auch immer, angehst, aber du musst auch so dein inneres,
Ego ab und zu mal ansägen und das hilft auf jeden Fall auch sehr und das ist immer so ein gutes,
Kriterium auch für Strukturen oder so, wenn man irgendwo ist,
weil die versuchen wir auch in unserer Organisationsform einfach immer wieder
zu zu überlegen, wie das gehen kann.
Weil ich glaube, das ist auf jeden Fall auch ein Geheimrezept,
dass man irgendwie gut gelaunt bleibt.
Das ist wichtig. Hille Nolz.
Das war jetzt so ein automatischer Schlusswort-Applaus.
Ja, vielleicht.
Ihr habt ja noch andere super Gäste. Ich weiß ja, wer es ist. Auf jeden Fall.
Nicht verraten. Vielen, vielen Dank für eure tolle Performance und natürlich,
dass du hier uns über das Quartiersmanagement und den Humor aufgeklärt hast
und über das Jodeln. Da muss man nochmal drüber reden.
1. Mai 25, Grunewald und 21. September gegen Proteste Schweigemacht.
So sieht's aus. Alles klar. Vielen Dank.
Danke.
Ich hab dir gesagt.
Das klappt. Mit dem, ist jetzt einfach mal geil.
Welcher Teil jetzt?
Alles.
Ach so, ja. Hab ich auch immer gesagt.
Am Ende funktioniert es dann doch immer irgendwo.
Kommen wir nun zu etwas ganz anderem.
Genau, kommen wir zu etwas vollkommen anderem. Wir haben ja auch,
wir denken ja auch viel über die Welt nach in diesem Podcast.
Und da muss man dann halt auch mal über die Welt reden.
Und da dachten wir uns, reden wir mal mit jemandem über die Welt,
die diese Welt sozusagen aber auch wirklich von der Vogelperspektive beobachtet,
von der Flugperspektive.
Wir begrüßen einen weiteren Gast.
Sie ist eine Art UFO-Expertin. Ihr werdet gleich feststellen, warum.
Macht auch Podcasts, aber im Kern ist sie eine Politikwissenschaftlerin,
die sich um die europäische Sicherheitspolitik Gedanken macht.
Sie würde jüngst als eine der zehn wichtigsten Think-Tankerinnen der deutschen
Sicherheitspolitik beschrieben. Ein komisches Wort, aber so ist es.
Und dabei muss sie auch viel über Krieg und Frieden nachdenken und hat sich
besonders dem Thema der Drohnentechnologie verschrieben.
Wir sagen herzlich willkommen bei Logbuch Netzpolitik, Ulrike Franke.
Irgendwo da hinten müsste sie aus dem Dunkeln zu uns treten. Ja.
Da kommt sie auch schon.
Super. Hi.
Setz dich, Kopfhörer auf.
So, ich mache diesmal auch gleich das Mikrofon an.
Kopfhörer auf.
Da bist du. Super. Hallo Rieke. Hallo. Super, dass du es geschafft hast.
Ja, danke für die Einladung.
Ganz toll. Ja, jetzt habe ich schon alles verraten über dich.
Ich hoffe, das traf halbwegs zu.
Der Begriff ist Denkfabrikantin.
Denkfabrikantin?
I mean.
Was machen Sie eigentlich so beruflich? Ich bin Denkfabrikantin.
Also besser als Pink Panther, oder?
Ja, das ist furchtbar. Ich habe das so gefunden. Und ehrlich gesagt,
ich hätte mir mal Gedanken darüber machen sollen.
Aber am Ende funktioniert es trotzdem irgendwie.
Ja, lass uns mal kurz mit deinem Hintergrund einsteigen. Du bist ja, also du hast studiert.
Ich habe studiert? Sehr, sehr lange. Ja, sehr lange.
Wie lange hast du denn studiert?
Oh, das will ich gar nicht verraten, weil ich habe ja promoviert.
Und die Promotion hat sich ewig gezogen, weil ich dann angefangen habe zu arbeiten,
weil ich eben über Drohnen promoviert habe und Drohnen so ein Thema sind,
was dann irgendwie auch sehr viel interessiert hat und ich finde eben auch,
wenn man in sozialwissenschaftlichen Themen promoviert oder eben arbeitet,
dann muss man auch versuchen, das irgendwie in die Gesellschaft reinzutragen,
weil Naturwissenschaften kann man von mir aus auch für die Forschung an sich machen,
sozialwissenschaftliche Themen halt nicht und insofern habe ich recht lange
promoviert und aber irgendwann wurde ich fertig, insofern wunderbar und seitdem mache ich das weiter.
Also Politikwissenschaft und Philosophie und Wirtschaft, stimmt das?
Ja, also ich habe in Frankreich studiert, also was du jetzt ansprichst,
das ist quasi der Bachelor und das ist dann so ein Studiengang,
da geht es um alles, was das mit Politik zu tun hat und da macht man eben so
ein bisschen eine Mischung.
Genau, so ein Rundumschlag und dann spezialisiert man sich hinterher.
Okay, genau. Und dann hast du, wie schon erwähnt, so Drohnen,
da reden wir gleich auch nochmal drüber.
Jetzt bist du, heutzutage hat man ja einen Beruf, also wenn man keinen Beruf
hat, wo der Titel auf Englisch ist, dann ist es auch irgendwie kein Beruf, ne?
Uns auf jeden Fall, ja.
Ich zitiere Senior Policy Fellow, was heißt denn sowas?
Das sind ausgedachte Titel in Thinktanks.
Ah ja, verstehe. Okay.
Auf einmal ergibt das alles Sinn.
Und Senior bedeutet dann auch nur, du warst jetzt eine Zeit lang da und wir
müssen dich irgendwie befördern.
Wir packen dann Senior vor, das klingt besser. Dann kann man auch mal nach einer
Gehaltserhöhung fragen.
Verstehe.
Was ich einfach mache, ist, ich beschäftige mich mit europäischer und viel deutscher,
Sicherheitsverteidigungspolitik, versuche die zu erklären.
Der Think Tank, bei dem ich arbeite, ist ein europäischer Thinktank soll heißen,
ich mache viel Deutschland erklären fürs europäische Ausland.
Also ich sitze in Paris zum Beispiel, die letzten Jahre war ich in London und
erkläre halt sehr viel irgendwie Deutschland und andersrum erkläre dann quasi
den Deutschen die Sicht von außen.
Und gerade in der Sicherheitsverteilungspolitik ist auch tatsächlich das,
was Berlin denkt und das, was Berlin denkt, was die Welt denkt,
oft so ein bisschen konträr.
Und insofern, glaube ich, braucht es diese Übersatzungsleistung da tatsächlich
und das ist halt sehr spannend.
Ja, also wir haben ja noch gar nicht gesagt, wo du das machst.
Das ist beim European Council on Foreign Relations.
Aber das ist quasi so eine private Struktur oder ist das in irgendeiner Form irgendwo verankert?
Das ist ein europäischer Think Tank mit Standorten in sieben europäischen Hauptstädten,
wie gesagt Paris, London, Berlin.
Wir sitzen hier ganz schön unter den Linden und in vielen anderen europäischen Städten.
Wir beschäftigen uns mit europäischer Außenpolitik, also nicht nur Sicherheitspolitik,
das mache ich jetzt, aber Außenpolitik im weitesten Sinne.
Und ja, wir werden finanziert von ganz vielen verschiedenen Stellen,
also wir sind nicht angedockt spezifisch jetzt irgendwie, weiß ich nicht,
an dem Deutschen Bundestag oder sowas, aber ich arbeite auch schon mal mit dem
Auswärtigen Amt oder auch mal mit dem Schweizer,
Auswärtigen Amt oder den Schweden oder einer Stiftung oder solchen,
Organisationen.
Also die kaufen dann, also ist das so eine Dienstleistung, die man dann einkauft oder wie,
berät sich da quasi die Politik mit solchen Organisationen?
Das hängt jetzt tatsächlich von dem Think Tank ab, das kann man schlecht generalisieren,
aber bei uns ist es eigentlich selten bis nie so, dass irgendwer kommt und sagt,
arbeitet jetzt mal spezifisch für uns an diesem Thema und das geht dann nur
an uns, also alles, was wir machen…,
99% der Sachen, wir machen auch schon mal eine Private Note irgendwie,
aber in sich 99% der Sachen sind dann auch öffentlich. Das heißt,
dann arbeite ich mit der Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung zusammen.
Die wollen natürlich irgendwie bestimmte Themen bespielen, was die interessiert.
Aber was ich dann schreibe, was wir machen, das ist dann öffentlich.
Aber da gibt es zum Beispiel auch Workshops oder Konferenzen.
Die sind dann natürlich nicht zwangsläufig für jeden, aber die sind jetzt nicht irgendwie geheim.
Insofern, das ist schon alles sehr transparent und alles, was ich mache,
wird letztendlich auch veröffentlicht.
Und das sind Studien dann?
Klassisches Format bei uns sind Studien, wobei bei uns immer so ein bisschen
der Running Gag ist, du musst quasi die 20 Seiten Studie schreiben,
die dann kein Mensch liest, damit du daraus, ja nicht eine PM, aber ein Op-Ed.
Also was du dann eigentlich machst, ist quasi das 800-Wort-Op-Ed für Politico
oder die FAZ oder die Zeit, basierend auf eben der ganzen Forschung,
die du da ein paar Monate oder auch ein paar Jahre, je nach Thema, gemacht hast.
Und damit beeinflusst du dann, ja, also Sie hoffen, das war ja gerade das Thema,
wie misst man eigentlich den Einfluss, den man hat, aber damit erzeugt man dann
vielleicht auch eine Öffentlichkeit oder ein Interesse für bestimmte Themen,
entweder wirklich in der breiten Öffentlichkeit oder bei politischen Entscheidungsträgern
oder Zuarbeiter der politischen Entscheidungsträger.
Und hast du dann da eine eigene Agenda oder ist das mehr so ein wissenschaftlicher
Blick auf die Gesamtsituation, Welche Situationen, wie siehst du dich da positioniert?
Also es ist beides. Es ist nicht rein wissenschaftlich. Es ist nicht nur zu
sagen so, dieses Thema muss irgendwie bearbeitet werden, dann hätte ich auch
an der Uni bleiben können.
Ich wollte schon immer, ich habe ja auch meine eigenen Überzeugungen.
Es ist selten, dass ich sage, das muss jetzt gemacht werden, Politik.
Diese Drohne müsst ihr kaufen. Das ist selten. Aber es ist schon so, dass ich sage, naja,
also zum Beispiel in Deutschland, Wir haben das sicherheits- und verteidigungspolitische
Thema in Deutschland über die letzten Jahrzehnte sträflich vernachlässigt.
Auf eine Art und Weise, wo wir wirklich gesagt haben, Verteidigung,
Militär, alles ganz schrecklich.
Alles Krieg und Aggression und wollen wir alles nicht.
Und ich verstehe natürlich, wo es herkommt. Ich verstehe auch...
Warum wir das so wollten, aber ich habe das immer schon als sehr problematisch
angesehen, weil nur wenn man sagt, wir wollen das ja alles nicht mehr,
heißt das ja nicht, dass der Rest der Welt das genauso sieht.
Und insofern, ja, habe ich eigentlich die letzten 10, 15 Jahre quasi gesagt,
wir müssen diese Themen mehr bespielen, wir müssen dazu mehr arbeiten,
wir müssen uns mit Militär und Verteidigung mehr auseinandersetzen,
wir müssen auch potenziell da
auch mehr selber machen, also Thema Unterfinanzierung, Bundeswehr und Co.
Und ja, dann kam der 24.
Februar 2022 und dann kam der 27.
Februar mit der Zeitenwende und da hat sich natürlich dann in meinem professionellen
Leben sehr viel verändert dahingehend.
Und wie gut, dass ihr zu diesem Zeitpunkt euch schon zusammengefunden habt, du,
Carlo, Masala, Frank Sauer und Thomas Wiegold zu einem Podcast,
denn ohne Podcast hat man heutzutage keinen Einfluss, Das kann ich also aus
erster Hand bestätigen.
Und da gehörst du natürlich fest zum Team, sicherheitshalber.
Ich habe mich sehr gefreut, als ihr damit angefangen habt, weil ich jahrelang
auf Thomas mal eingeredet habe, dass dein Thema und deine Stimme irgendwie das
gehört in einen Podcast.
Und dann, weiß nicht, war er da eigentlich derjenige, der das dann zusammengetrieben
hat oder wer war die treibende Kraft?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Also erstmal, um das zu erklären für diejenigen,
die uns jetzt nicht hören oder Thomas Wiegold nicht kennen.
Thomas Wiegold hat eine fantastische Bassstimme.
Ja, stimmt. Das ist einfach.
Das ist die Stimme.
Also der müsste Kinderbücher vertonen oder irgendwie.
Der hat jetzt seinen Beruf verfehlt.
Und Thomas Wiegold ist einer der ganz, ganz,
ganz, ganz wenigen deutschen Journalisten, die sich wirklich seit vielen Jahren
intensiv und mit Expertise mit den Themen Sicherheit und auch wirklich spezifisch
Verteidigungs- und Militärpolitik auseinandergesetzt haben.
Und der Bundeswehr, genau.
Und das machte halt, also vor der Zeitenwende, also da konnte man es an einer
Hand abzählen, inzwischen kann man die Leute vielleicht an zwei Händen abzählen,
aber es ist halt wirklich sehr wenig.
Und genau, Thomas Wegeld ist einer der drei Mitstreiter, also eben, wir sind vier.
Wir haben uns, wir haben irgendwie auch so ein bisschen unterschiedliche Erzählungen
in dieser Entstehungsgeschichte, weil wir alle gleichzeitig so ein bisschen
der Meinung waren, da müsste man noch mehr machen.
Thema, es wird in Deutschland zu wenig darüber darüber gesprochen.
Wir machen zwar alle Medienarbeit, also eben auch schon vor jetzt irgendwie
dem Krieg gegen die Ukraine, aber es ist halt einfach wirklich was anderes, ob man,
im Deutschlandfunk drei Minuten lang erklären darf, wofür jetzt die Senate-Übung
da ist oder mal wirklich sagen kann, okay, wir diskutieren jetzt mal 55 Minuten,
wie funktioniert das eigentlich alles und macht das eigentlich Sinn und wofür
ist das eigentlich alles da?
Und da haben wir uns tatsächlich so ein bisschen zusammengefunden,
alle gleichzeitig Ich hätte schon gesagt,
Bei mir fing es an, dass ich gefragt habe, was gibt es denn eigentlich in Deutschland
an Podcasts? Weil ich kannte ja die englische Podcastwelt und hörte da,
was ist echt der deutsche sicherheitspolitische Podcast?
Und dann kam die Aussage, gibt es nicht. Und dann war so ein bisschen die Reaktion,
ja, sollte man das ja vielleicht mal machen.
Und dann haben wir uns zusammengefunden auf unterschiedliche Wege.
Also ich kannte Frank sehr gut, Frank hat Carlo sehr gut.
Wir alle kannten irgendwie Thomas und haben uns gefunden und haben gesagt,
das sollten wir jetzt machen. Das war vor sechs Jahren.
Im Übrigen ist es eben auch ein Podcast, deswegen hat mir das Vorgespräch so
gut gefallen. der eben trotz des schweren Themas auch immer versucht,
unterhaltsam und ja, zum gewissen Grade eben auch humorvoll zu sein.
Also eben hieß es Humor entwaffnet. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist es dann bei
uns Humor bewaffnet, aber die Idee ist eben zu sagen,
das soll man eben auch hören und nicht die ganze Zeit bierernst da sitzen und
entweder so einer Vorlesung folgen oder sich gedenken, um Gottes Willen,
wie schrecklich ist die Welt,
irgendwie alles Krieg und Panzer und so weiter, sondern es soll irgendwo auch
wie gesagt unterhaltsam und humorvoll sein natürlich lachen wir nie über Krieg und Leid,
das wird uns gar nicht einfallen aber wir lachen eben sehr viel über uns und
die Situation ist komisch und das macht es dann für uns nett und offensichtlich
auch so hörbar, dass es ein paar Leute hören Ich.
Glaube die Politik gibt auch immer genug her da kann man sich auf jeden Fall
ordentlich die Bräuche halten das ist ja alles ein Drama für sich Ich finde
es eine brillante Runde Wer den Podcast noch nicht kennt, das kann ich gerne weiterempfehlen.
Ja, und ich dachte, das passt auch ganz gut zu uns, weil wir ja auch so ein
bisschen Unterhaltungsprogramm machen, so am Rande der Apokalypse.
Wir sind ja sozusagen, ich kann das ja mal kurz demonstrieren,
wir sind der einzige Podcast, der für gute Nachrichten einen eigenen Jingle hat.
Jetzt musst du eine gute Nachricht, außer Sicherheitspolitik.
Das ist immer so lustig, bei unseren guten Nachrichten, da denken sich teilweise
die Leute so, das ist jetzt irgendwie die gute Nachricht?
Also in letzter Zeit ist das ja dann wirklich, wie gesagt, das ist dann eben
gut in Anführungsstrichen, aber eben nach dem Motto, so dieses Waffensystem
wurde jetzt endlich gekauft.
Das ist natürlich, also verstehe ich auch, dass es jetzt nicht so klingt nach
so der guten Nachricht, aber teilweise in unserer Welt, weil in unserer Welt, ich sage auch oft,
in unserer Welt sind oft alle Optionen so ein bisschen schlecht und man versucht
die Beste der Schlechten zu finden.
Und das erklärt im Übrigen auch, warum niemand Sicherheitspolitiker sein will
und Verteidigungspolitiker, weil du halt quasi immer, was du verkaufst,
ist halt so die Beste der schlechten Optionen und dein super duper Idealszenario ist,
wir geben Milliarden und Milliarden auf für Waffensysteme, die wir nie einsetzen.
Das ist so nonplusultra der Sicherheitspolitik.
Ist natürlich jetzt irgendwie so als Plakatwand nicht so geil wie ich baue fünf
Kindergärten, kann ich auch verstehen.
Ja, also du hast ja schon gesagt, die,
Sicherheitspolitik ist sagen wir mal als Genre jetzt auch ein bisschen ins öffentliche
Bewusstsein geraten durch den,
ja, ich will gar nicht von einem Beginn des Krieges reden, weil es ist ja eigentlich
nur die Fortsetzung eines ohnehin schon sehr lange tobenden Krieges,
mindestens zehn Jahre, man kann das beliebig weit nach hinten verlängern.
Also dieser gesamte Konflikt um Russland und die Ukraine, der ja letzten Endes
auch ein Kampf um Europa ist.
Jetzt bist du ja gleich mit,
Doppelt sozusagen da im Sturm, einerseits jetzt mit eurer eigenen medialen Präsenz,
aber eben auch so als Sicherheitsberaterin, kann man das eigentlich auch so sagen?
Berätst du oder Forscherin, also Denkfabrikantin ist ja jetzt wahrscheinlich
nicht dein Go-To-Word, oder?
Nee, also zwischen Forscherin und Beraterin mehr Forscherin.
Das ist im Übrigen tatsächlich bei Thinktankern sehr individuell.
Also man kann den Job da auch sehr formen. Und ich habe Kollegen,
die, weiß ich nicht, gehen zum Beispiel viel häufiger, sagen wir mal,
in den Bundestag und sprechen da mit Abgeordneten.
Und ich mache, würde ich jetzt sagen, mehr vielleicht auch wirklich öffentlichere
Arbeit mit Medien und Co.
Aber genau, es ist so ein bisschen was dazwischen. Und klar,
man spricht eben auch, also es gibt auch Beratungsmomente, dann spreche ich
eben mit, das ist auch oft ein Austausch ehrlich gesagt, aber eben mit der Politik,
auch mit dem Militär, auch mit der Verteidigungsindustrie.
Also da ist man im ständigen Austausch und ja, dann sage ich eben auch,
was ich denke und was ich weiß.
Das kann man vielleicht als Beratung bezeichnen, aber es ist tatsächlich mehr ein Austausch.
Also du gehst dann zu der Verteidigungsindustrie und sagst so,
Jungs, was bauen wir heute für eine Waffe oder hier,
wir brauchen was, was gegen diesen oder jeden Panzer, Das Doofe ist,
ich kann mir das wirklich sehr schwer vorstellen,
wenn du das so ein bisschen plastischer machen könntest, weil ich weiß,
dass Menschen sich damit auseinandersetzen,
ich weiß, dass es ja auch irgendwo sitzen ja Leute, die planen Waffensysteme,
die führen diese Kriege und dann gibt es euch, die das eben auch auf einem globalen
politischen Feld betrachten, aber welche,
also was sind so, wenn man jetzt das konkretere Thema greift, worüber sprecht ihr da?
Also mit der Verteidigungsindustrie, wie gesagt, absoluten Austausch.
Sie erzählen mir quasi eher dann auch, was Sie bauen oder wann Sie forschen oder so.
Ich würde dann nie sagen, dieses und jenes irgendwie muss gebaut werden.
Das ist jetzt nicht meine Baustelle.
Aber ich kann zum Beispiel eben sagen, okay, aufgrund meiner Forschung der Drohneneinsätze,
der USA und der Briten und der Deutschen in Afghanistan und Co.
Wo wissen wir, an was es quasi auch gefehlt hat.
Also nicht nur an Fähigkeiten, sondern auch, was wurde eingesetzt,
was hat irgendwie gut funktioniert, wie wurden Dinge auch aufs Schlachtfeld
gebracht, wie haben die Soldaten gelernt, wo braucht es vielleicht auch mehr
Training. Das wäre so Themen.
Und ein anderes Thema, wo ich zum Beispiel, das ist jetzt auch nicht irgendwie
geheim, ich bin Teil von einer Gruppe,
die hat Airbus gemeinsam mit dem Fraunhofer-Institut ins Leben gerufen.
Das nennt sich, ich glaube, Arbeitsgruppe Technik Verantwortung,
wenn ich mich nicht irre.
Und das ist eine Gruppe von Experten aus Wissenschaft, Politik,
teilweise Stiftung, ich glaube, es ist sogar jemand von der Evangelischen Kirche
dabei, von der Bundeswehr.
Und wir beschäftigen uns spezifisch mit der Frage von Technik.
Autonomie und künstliche Intelligenz in neuen Waffensystemen und ganz konkret
geht es darum, dass Airbus eines der Unternehmen ist, was an dem FCAS-Projekt baut.
FKs, Future Combat Air System, das ist ein Kampfflugzeug plus,
was Deutschland, Frankreich und Spanien zusammen.
Bauen, sehr, sehr viel Geld und das soll eben in den 2040ern fliegen und da
wird allein schon, weil es in den 2040ern fliegen soll, sehr viel künstliche
Intelligenz und Autonomie und sowas verbaut.
Und dann sprechen eben die mit uns, die wir uns damit akademisch oder politisch
mit beschäftigen und wir loten quasi so ein bisschen aus, was sind die Probleme,
Was sind die Probleme ethischer Natur?
Was sind die Probleme politischer Natur? Wie kann man das irgendwie machen?
Natürlich sagen wir denen nicht, bau das Flugzeug so oder so,
habe ich überhaupt keine, kann ich gar nicht.
Aber man spricht eben die Problematiken an und das gibt dann Airbus wieder eine
neue Sicht und ja, also deswegen Austausch.
Aber das heißt, da arbeiten Leute schon heute daran, dass in 16 Jahren KI-Kampfflugzeuge
diesen Planeten irgendwie sicher machen?
Ja, aber das ist schon, die arbeiten nicht heute dran, dass sie das in 16 Jahren
machen, sondern die gibt es jetzt schon.
Also wir haben jetzt künstliche Intelligenz auf den Schlachtfeldern dieser Welt,
inklusive in der Ukraine, die auch Systemen sehr viel Autonomie geben.
Und das ist alles quasi schon verbaut. Aber genau, natürlich geht das immer
auch, also Militärprojekte sind auch immer sehr große Langzeitprojekte.
Da denkt man eben in Dekaden. Das erklärt auch so ein bisschen,
warum Zeitenwende auch teilweise so schleppend vorangeht.
2040 ist da eben so ein Zeithorizont. Aber genau, darüber wird nachgedacht,
darüber wird geforscht, daran wird gebaut.
Und weil es eben nicht so ist, dass die Verteidigungsindustrie einfach nur irgendwie
coole Waffen bauen will und das Militär einfach nur irgendwie coole Waffen haben
will, die schießen, das stimmt halt alles so nicht, setzen sich Leute halt zusammen
und sagen, wie können wir hier etwas bauen,
das die Fähigkeiten hat, die wir brauchen für unsere Verteidigung,
aber gleichzeitig eben auch im Einklang stehen mit unseren zum Beispiel eben
ethischen Vorstellungen oder politischen Vorgaben.
Es ist zum Beispiel interessant, dieses FK-Flugzeug wird ein bemanntes Flugzeug
sein selber und dann gibt es, also das ist das aktuelle Konzept,
und dann gibt es einen Drohnenschwarm drumherum, eine sogenannte Kampfwolke,
Verbindung mit anderen.
Aber die Tatsache, dass man eben von einem bemannten Flugzeug ausgeht,
das ist eigentlich vor allen Dingen auch eine politische Vorgabe, wenn man das möchte.
Weil man, weil diese Idee der Drohne, die man einfach nur irgendwo hinschickt,
um da was kaputt zu machen, ohne menschliche Kontrolle dann nicht,
also ethisch nicht trägt, oder?
Das ist die Debatte. Also ich glaube in dem Fall...
Macht man sich ein bisschen was vor, wenn man denkt, nur weil ich da einen Piloten
oder eine Pilotin in ein Cockpit setze, habe ich damit zwangsläufig mehr sogenannte,
wir lieben die englischen Begriffe, meaningful human control,
also quasi vernünftige menschliche Kontrolle.
Um die genau geht es? Wie kann man die quasi haben? Oder wo ist sie nötig?
Wo ist sie vielleicht auch nicht nötig?
Wie können wir sicher gehen, dass sie da ist? Ob jetzt der Pilot,
die Pilotin im Cockpit irgendwie das Nonplusultra ist, ist so ein bisschen die Frage.
Aber genau, da kommt das meines Erachtens vor allen Dingen her, dieser Versuch.
Und wenn du sagst, in den Kriegen dieser Welt kommen jetzt schon KI-Systeme
oder Automatisierungssysteme zum Einsatz, wie muss ich mir das vorstellen?
Also du merkst, ich habe nicht so viel Ahnung von diesem Thema.
Musst du UKW hören, da wird ganz viel darüber geredet.
Oder sicherheitshalber wahrscheinlich auch.
Oder Sicherheitshalber.
Ich meinte aber KI.
Ja, ja, nee. Da kommen wir gerade auf einen wirklich interessanten Punkt.
Also du hast dich ja, das fand ich auch sehr interessant, du hast dich ja schon
relativ früh, 2018, schon mit deiner Dissertation mit Drohnen beschäftigt.
Und ich erinnere mich noch ganz gut daran, wie so Drohnen in der Öffentlichkeit
wahrgenommen wurden und speziell auch, sagen wir mal so, in unserem Heimatbereich
der technologisch affinen Menschen so...
War das immer etwas, was sehr in der Kritik stand.
Und die Angst vor diesen autonomen Waffen, die selbst entscheiden,
der durchautomatisiert ist, wo irgendwie der Mensch irgendwo in Texas im Kontrollzentrum
sitzt, aber fernwirkt irgendwo im Irak.
Das ist etwas, was den Leuten noch mal zusätzlich Angst gemacht hat über das
normale Kriegsszenario hinaus auch.
Aber warum eigentlich? Also da gibt es doch bestimmt Forschung zu oder Auseinandersetzung zu, weil...
Wenn da automatische Entscheidungen getroffen werden, okay, aber was ist es,
was die Menschen daran so beschäftigt, dass da jetzt ein Mensch drin ist oder
nicht? Also macht das...
Da ist ja ein Mensch drin, aber der Mensch ist halt nicht mehr selber vor Ort.
Das ist, glaube ich, so ein Punkt.
Also wenn du im Flugzeug sitzt, dann bist du ja beteiligt und wir nehmen ja immer an...
Ja, denkt man, aber das ist ja sozusagen unsere Erwartung. Ja,
du bist im Kriegsgeschehen, dann kannst du das auch alles besser einschätzen
oder dann hast du eine Meinung dazu oder dann kannst du irgendwie Abwägungen
treffen und wenn man jetzt ein paar tausend Kilometer auf einem anderen Kontinent
sitzt und das fernsteuert, dann ist dem halt nicht so.
Aber ich dachte, genau deswegen macht man das.
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Das ist ja auch eine technische Ökonomiefrage letzten Endes
auch und eine Gewerdung von Personen im Einsatz.
Ich würde das gerne auch gleich mal vertiefen, gerade weil ja natürlich jetzt
der Ukraine-Krieg jetzt alles sozusagen in den Turbo-Modus geschaltet hat.
Also wir erleben eine unfassbare technologische Entwicklung,
speziell eben auch jetzt in der Ukraine,
die also da hunderte von Startups gefördert hat,
die also einen Wildwuchs an hunderten verschiedenen Modellen und Varianten von
Drohnen, von diesen Kamikaze-Drohnen,
Überwachungsdrohnen, sonstige Spezialsysteme, die jetzt auch in die Ferne gehen.
Jetzt Paglianiza, die neueste Technologie, die sie gerade vorgestellt haben,
also in einer unheimlich hohen Geschwindigkeit findet das jetzt statt.
Wie blickst du da drauf und was denkst du passiert da jetzt gerade mit Krieg und so weiter?
Da waren jetzt viele Fragen drin. Wenn ich nicht auf der Bühne podcaste,
habe ich dann meinen Notizblock und dann kann ich das alles aufschreiben.
Insofern, ich versuche mal die Punkte, die mir aufgefallen sind, rauszugreifen.
Also erstmal vielleicht, was interessant war an eurer Debatte auch,
das hat so ein bisschen auch die Malaise der deutschen Drohnendebatte aufgezeigt.
Wir haben uns in Deutschland, würde ich wirklich so sagen, eine unsägliche Drohnendebatte
geleistet, die politisch eigentlich unverantwortlich war.
Wir haben über mehr als zehn Jahre darüber diskutiert, ob die Bundeswehr bewaffnete,
ferngesteuerte Drohnen bekommen soll.
Zehn Jahre hat es gedauert, inzwischen haben wir fünf bewaffnete Drohnen von Israel geleased.
Kann man leasen?
Ja, das ist ein Prinzip, wir haben die davor auch schon gelistet,
das sind alles Übergangslösungen für wenn wir was eigenes bauen,
was wir dann nie tun, aber sei es drum.
5.5, bewaffnete Drohnen von Israel gelistet.
Da haben wir in dieser Drohnen-Diskussion in Deutschland unglaublich viel zusammen
und durcheinander geschmissen.
Und das war ehrlich gesagt auch so ein Teil meiner Motivation,
meiner Doktorarbeit, dass ich gesagt
habe, wir haben hier so eine seltsame Diskussion, wir reden über das,
aber dann schmeißt jemand das ein und dann sagt jemand Killerroboter und es
macht alles keinen Sinn.
Denn was wir zu dem Zeitpunkt hatten und was wir jetzt eben auch in Deutschland
aktuell einsetzen, da geht es um ferngesteuerte, größere bewaffnete Drohnen.
Das sind, ich vereinfache jetzt so ein bisschen die Systeme,
die die Amerikaner nutzen, um eben von den USA irgendwie weiter weg Krieg zu führen.
Wir können das übrigens nicht auf diese Distanzen, wenn wir in Afghanistan eine
Drohne haben, dann müssen wir auch in Afghanistan sitzen, dann sitzen wir zwar
im sicheren Feldlager und nicht direkt auf dem Schlachtfeld,
aber wir können das nicht irgendwie von Berlin aus,
aber das sind eben ferngesteuerte Systeme und da kommt diese ganze Debatte rein
von, ist das jetzt besser oder schlechter, wenn der Pilot, die Pilotin,
der Kontrolleur nicht im Cockpit sitzt und was bedeutet das?
Und es gibt eben das eine Argument, das geht in Richtung Cubicle Warrior, also quasi.
Die Soldaten, die entfremdet sind ihrem Tun, die quasi vor einem Bildschirm
sitzen in einem klimatisierten Raum in Nevada,
ist in den USA tatsächlich so, in der Nähe von Las Vegas, die fahren jeden Morgen
zur Arbeit, setzen sich an ihren Schreibtisch, führen Krieg im Irak morgens
und nachmittags in Afghanistan.
Das ist auch tatsächlich so gewesen und dann fahren sie quasi wieder nach Hause
und dann bringen sie quasi die Pixel auf den Bildschirm und das ist so das eine Extrem.
Da sind Elemente daran, sind nicht falsch.
Ich kann jetzt nicht so viel ins Detail gehen, aber Elemente davon sind nicht
falsch. Die andere Realität ist aber eben auch, dass man sagen kann,
naja, aber anstatt da einen Piloten, eine Pilotin in einem Flugzeug zu haben,
haben wir da jetzt plötzlich ein riesen Team sitzen.
Das ist nämlich nicht nur einer, das ist dann ein Team von verschiedenen Leuten,
die haben inklusive noch irgendwie juristischen Beistand dabei und die können
dir genau sagen, ist das jetzt eine gute Idee, da eine Bombe drauf zu schmeißen.
Das ist so das Erste, das hat der Pilot nicht. Sie haben auch unendlich Zeit.
Pilot, Pilotin, Kampfflugzeuge haben eine unglaublich kurze Flugdauer.
Du fliegst da los, du schmeißt eine Bombe, du fliegst wieder zurück und hast
nämlich keinen Sprit mehr.
Drohnen können ewig in der Luft bleiben. 24 Stunden, 30 Stunden bei den Systemen.
Wenn die im Relay fliegen, für immer und ewig.
Sieben Tage können die einem Ziel hinterher fliegen, um wirklich sicher zu sein,
dass es das Richtige ist.
Und, und das ist das, was ich eben mit dem denkste, von wegen,
dass der Pilot irgendwie näher dran ist.
Ich habe halt auch Interviews geführt. das war jetzt ein deutscher Drohnenpilot
damals noch unbewaffnet, wir haben lange.
Überwachungstronen einfach gehabt ein deutscher Drohnenpilot in Afghanistan,
und der flog vorher und auch glaube ich immer noch zeitgleich auch Tornados,
also eben bemannte Flugzeuge und der sagte mir so,
bei dem einen sitze ich in meinem Flugzeug, fliege habe Koordinaten und da schmeiße
ich eine Bombe drauf oder mache eben Überwachung,
aber ich habe eigentlich keine Ahnung was am Boden vorgeht und dann fliege ich
wieder zurück Und hinterher habe ich die Bilder oder eben potenziell den Schaden am Boden.
Bei der Drohne bin ich da stundenlang unterwegs und gucke mir an,
was passiert in dem Haus, was macht der Typ, ist das irgendwie mein Ziel?
Der spielt mit seinen Kindern.
Sind das Kinder, muss ich auch identifizieren und so weiter und so fort.
Und ich habe eine ganz andere emotionale Nähe. Und das sind so die beiden Wahrheiten.
Wie gesagt, das ist nicht so, das eine ist wahr und das andere ist falsch oder
vice versa. Das ist irgendwie so beides.
Und Ziel, auch meiner Forschung im Übrigen, ist dann natürlich zu sagen,
okay, das eine klingt ja offensichtlich wie eine dumme Idee.
Wir wollen keine Cubicle Warriors.
Wir wollen nicht Leute, die quasi irgendwie wahllos Menschen wie Pixel auf dem
Screen irgendwie umbringen.
Wir wollen aber im Übrigen auch nicht die erhöhte Belastung,
dass wir sehen hier genau, was passiert und haben vielleicht irgendwie Albträume
von dem, was wir tun, sondern wir wollen eben.
Wenn wir der Meinung sind, dass dieser Einsatz richtig ist und dass dieser Krieg
geführt werden muss, wollen wir ihn auf eine Art führen, der mit unseren Werten
im Einklang steht, der möglichst gut ist für unsere Soldaten,
ich weiß nicht, wie man das besser formulieren kann.
Und genau, so bringt man das dann quasi zusammen.
So, und jetzt, sorry, jetzt habe ich sehr lange gesprochen über quasi das eine,
und das ist halt eben das, was wir zum Beispiel in Deutschland haben,
die ferngesteuerten Drohnen.
Aber jetzt gibt es eben die ganze Entwicklung hin zu dem unsäglichen Begriff der Killer-Roboter.
Wir haben eben zunehmend eine Automatisierung und mehr Autonomie in der Kriegsführung.
Das heißt, es werden einfach mehr Entscheidungen an die Maschine abgegeben.
Das hängt meistens damit zusammen, dass man schneller sein will oder muss.
Es gibt gerade den Druck, schneller zu sein. Teilweise gibt es auch den Druck,
dass man vielleicht weniger Soldaten dafür braucht.
Das ist nicht unbedingt immer der Fall. Aber genau und dahin geht momentan sehr
die Entwicklung, dass wir eben Systeme haben, die ja selber entscheiden können,
wo sie zum Beispiel hinfliegen, was sie ansehen, identifizieren können ein Ziel
und potenziell eben auch selber bombardieren, wenn man das eben so eingestellt hat.
Meistens ist es jetzt noch so, dass man die Rückfrage hat, soll ich das bombardieren
oder nicht, aber technisch braucht man die nicht mehr.
Und das ist so ein bisschen eben diese Entwicklung, die wir haben und wie du
gesagt hast, Ukraine hat das Ganze,
wie jeder Krieg im Übrigen, Kriege sind immer Innovationsschübe und Testfelder
für neue technologische Entwicklungen und das sehen wir eben da ganz stark,
dass wir da immer mehr, ja,
also diese Entwicklung hin zu mehr Autonomie, mehr Küstchenintelligenz etc.
In der Kriegsführung haben.
Ich habe aber den Eindruck, also Ukraine ist jetzt auch wirklich,
ich meine, das ist ja ein Land, was ja schon früher extrem stark in der Waffenentwicklung
unterwegs war und sich auch sehr, ich weiß nicht, es ist ein sehr innovatives Land.
Ich war da, da kann man überall mit Karte bezahlen. Gut, das geht eigentlich überall.
Unsere Ansprüche sind gering.
Wenn wir aus Deutschland kommen.
Ein innovatives Land, ich habe meine Karte.
Ja, aber das ist ein digitales Land irgendwie so. Also die verstehen,
wie das funktioniert und die sind in der Lage, das irgendwie für sich auch alles
nutzbringend zur Anwendung zu bringen. Das merkt man schon.
Aber jetzt sind wir ja schon an so einer Grenze, habe ich so den Eindruck.
Vielleicht schwierig immer so klar zu benennen, wo jetzt irgendwas anfängt oder nicht.
Also auf der einen Seite gibt es jetzt so eben autonome Systeme,
gerade um jetzt diese elektronische, also Electronic Warfare meint man ja sozusagen
der Kampf um das elektromagnetische Spektrum,
der da stattfindet, um sozusagen zu verhindern, dass man mit ferngesteuerten
Systemen irgendwie rankommt, führt ja jetzt dazu, dass man in zunehmendem Maße,
Systeme baut, die dann eben auch ihre Ziele selber finden.
Und ich glaube, das ist dann auch wieder so ein bisschen Teil eines Szenarios,
was viele sich gar nicht vorstellen wollen, dass irgendwann nur noch so Maschinen
herumfliegen, die quasi selber eine Zielauswahl machen und,
gestern war es noch das Unkraut auf dem Acker, was automatisch weggelasert wird.
Demnächst haben wir so den Skynet Laser in den Wolken, der dann sozusagen die Leute weglasert.
Wie verfolgst du diese Debatte, was löst das bei dir aus?
Also ich verfolge sie grundsätzlich mit Sorge, denn ich glaube,
wir alle haben erst intuitiv und wenn man darüber nachdenkt,
auch quasi aus guten Gründen, eine Abneigung gegen die Überlegung,
Maschinen bringen selbstständig Menschen um.
Aber es ist eben wichtig, das auch zu hinterfragen. Warum eigentlich? Was ist das Problem?
Welcher Kontext ist quasi das Problem? Also das erste, was mir wichtig ist zu
sagen, ist, es geht weniger um autonome Waffen als um Autonomie in der Waffentechnik.
Und ich sage das deswegen, als dass wir zunehmende Autonomie und auch immer
mehr künstliche Intelligenz in ganz vielen verschiedenen Waffengattungen auch haben.
Also es ist weniger, dass wir sagen, da baut jetzt jemand den Killer-Roboter
oder den Terminator und dann hat man dieses Ding und das ist dann quasi das
autonome Waffensystem.
Sondern es ist eher so, dass ganz viele, man nennt das auch Legacy-Systeme,
also eben die schon existierenden Systeme modernisiert werden, upgegradet werden.
Die können dann eben mehr, die machen dann mehr autonome Zielführung oder können
mehr selbst Daten analysieren.
Und das ist ja an sich auch nicht falsch.
Also mir ist auch immer sehr wichtig zu sagen, okay, was genau ist das Problem?
Und das Problem ist ja nicht, wenn Waffen besser werden, denn bessere Waffen
sind ja a priori präzisere Waffen und präzisere Waffen sind die Waffen,
die dann eben nur die Leute treffen, die man treffen will.
Und ich verstehe, wenn man grundsätzlich dagegen ist, dass Waffen Leute treffen,
dann ist einem das auch alles egal, aber wenn man grundsätzlich der Meinung
ist, man braucht schon mal manchmal auch Waffen und manchmal eben auch Waffen,
um Leute zu treffen, dann will ich aber auch Waffen, die wirklich nur die Leute
treffen, die ich treffen will und nicht alle drumherum.
Und insofern gibt es da auch eben technologische Entwicklungen,
wo man sagt, die sind an sich nicht gut.
Wenn die Maschine besser ist als der Mensch, dann müssen wir darüber nachdenken,
ob wir die Maschine einsetzen.
Aber wo ist die Grenze und wo ist das Problem? Und wo sagen wir auch als Gesellschaft,
irgendwie ist das ethisch, moralisch falsch, zu sagen, die Maschine trifft die Entscheidung.
Wer übernimmt dann quasi die Verantwortung?
Wer übernimmt die Verantwortung für den Tod eines anderen Menschen?
Das sind genau diese ethischen Fragen.
Persönlich muss ich sagen, weil das auch mehr mein Beritt ist,
finde ich die sicherheitspolitischen Implikationen in dieser ganzen Entwicklung
noch relevanter und interessanter.
Also nicht so sehr die Frage, inwieweit Autonomie jetzt quasi ethisch vertretbar
ist, sondern was könnte das geopolitisch machen?
Denn die eine Riesensorge, die ich habe, ist, dass wir auf einen Rüstungswettlauf
zusteuern Und ein Rüstungswettläufer, um das zu verstehen, ist nicht einfach.
X kauft mehr Waffen und Y kauft mehr Waffen und alle statten sich mehr aus.
Es gibt meines Erachtens keinen Rüstungswettlauf bei den Drohnen,
sondern alle kaufen irgendwie mehr, weil das gerade die neue Technologie ist.
Okay, kann man blöd finden, ist aber jetzt kein Rüstungswettlauf.
Ein Rüstungswettlauf ist, wenn quasi X eine Waffe kauft und Y fühlt sich,
weil X gekauft hat, gezwungen darauf zu reagieren und kauft sich dann auch diese Waffe.
Und dann sagt X wieder, oh, jetzt fühle ich mich aber bedroht,
jetzt muss ich irgendwie auch dagegen halten und so weiter und so fort.
Und das ist eskalatorisch.
Und eskalatorisch ist schlecht, weil eskalatorisch destabilisierend ist,
eskalatorisch ist finanziell ruinös.
Und eskalatorisch bedeutet eben immer, dass du dann vielleicht zu einem Punkt
kommst, wo einer sagt, jetzt bin ich aber gerade oben.
Und jetzt greife ich lieber den anderen an, bevor der wieder nachzieht.
Und die Gefahr sehe ich ganz stark, oder das ist so meine Sorge,
dass es die so ein bisschen inhärent in der Autonomie von Waffen gibt.
Gibt, weil es eben sein kann, dass quasi autonome Waffen, KI-unterstützte Waffen
so schnell vor allen Dingen auch werden, dass die einzige Art und Weise,
auf sie zu antworten, auch wieder mehr Autonomie und mehr KI ist.
Und dann wird man quasi gezwungen, darauf zu reagieren, auf eine Art und Weise,
wie man vielleicht gar nicht wollte.
Und dann kommt man eben in diese ungünstige Spirale.
Und das ist so was, wo wir zum Beispiel politisch, geopolitisch,
internationalpolitisch entgegenwirken sollten. Das ist ein Beispiel.
Es gibt noch andere, Flashwars und all so weiter. Also es gibt da viele Szenarien,
wo wir sagen, sicherheitspolitischen Problemen und vielleicht eben auch hoffentlich
eine Motivation, selbst in der aktuellen Situation,
wo alle miteinander verfeindet sind, über Rüstungskontrolle und internationale Regeln zu sprechen.
Also verstehe ich dich richtig, du siehst uns jetzt gerade auf diesem Weg in
so eine eskalatorische Dynamik oder?
Ich habe die Sorge, denn wir gehen technologisch immer mehr dahin.
Also wer sind wir in dem Zusammenhang?
Alle diejenigen Länder in dem Fall, die Waffen bauen und Waffen entwickeln und KI entwickeln.
Also quasi vor allen Dingen eben die Großmächte.
Natürlich ist immer der Augenmerk, wenn es jetzt wirklich um die ganz großen
geopolitischen Fragen geht, irgendwie US und China.
Also mit wir meinst du jetzt nicht die NATO, der Westen, sondern du meinst alle Beteiligten?
Der kriegführende Planet.
Der kriegführende Planet, also der Rüstungswettlauf, die Gefahr eines Rüstungswettlaufs
ist am akutesten wirklich zwischen den USA und China.
Und bei der USA spielt natürlich dann der vereinte Westen und NATO-Länder und
so mit rein, aber es ist dann vor allen Dingen eben USA und China.
Bei anderen Themen wie, also sogenannte Flash Wars im Sinne von,
es wird so viel Autonomie in Systeme gepackt, dass man quasi dann Kriege bekommt,
wo nur die Maschinen aufeinander reagieren und quasi Kriege oder zumindest Konflikte auslösen.
Ja, da komme ich sofort zu. Sie habe ich mich auch direkt zu. Das wäre doch gut.
Die quasi einen Krieg auslösen und dann kämpfen die Maschinen gegeneinander.
Ja, okay. Aber dann denk das mal weiter.
Dann sind die Maschinen kaputt.
Ja, und dann?
Dann fangen wir wieder neue an zu bauen.
Aber dann, und das ist mir ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, es ist leider nicht so
in der Geschichte, dass man sagt, wir bauen irgendwie die Waffen und die ersetzen
dann quasi das Vorherige und das fällt dann irgendwie weg.
Was wahrscheinlicher ist, ist, dass was wir jetzt bauen quasi obendrauf kommt.
Es kann schon sein, dass der nächste große Krieg, von dem wir alle hoffen,
dass er nicht passiert, irgendwie erst anfängt mit man schießt die Satelliten
ab. Okay, ist noch keiner gestorben.
Die Cyberkriegsführung gegeneinander. Computer irgendwie gegen Computer.
Okay, ist auch noch keiner gestorben. Wobei, je nachdem, was da getroffen wird,
geht das dann schnell. Aber sei es drum.
Aber der Punkt ist doch, und dann geht von mir aus die autonome Drohne gegen die autonome Drohne.
Aber der Punkt ist doch, dann gewinnt meine Seite, meine autonome Drohne gegen deine autonome Drohne.
Dann sagst du doch nicht, ach, schade, habe ich verloren. Okay.
Und ziehst dich zurück. Was passiert dann? Ja, dann kommen eben die Soldaten,
dann kommen die Panzer. Und am Ende, und das ist echt immer der Punkt,
am Ende hast du den 18-jährigen Rekruten, der irgendwo im Schützengraben liegt und stirbt.
Und deswegen ist diese ganze Idee von so einer Technik-Kriegsführung nach dem Motto so,
wir lassen die Maschinen es zueinander ausmachen und das wird jetzt irgendwie
der saubere Technologie-Krieg eben Quatsch,
weil am Ende Krieg ist immer ein menschliches Unterfangen und die Seite wird
eben immer erst aufgeben, eben wenn sie nicht mehr können und zwar nicht,
wenn deren Maschinen nicht mehr können, sondern wenn der Land nicht mehr kann. Das ist so die Gefahr.
Das ist jetzt leider nicht so applauswürdig.
Ach, jeder schlüssige Gedanke ist applauswürdig. Ja, Krieg ist ja so eine Binsenweisheit.
Ich habe gerade vergessen, wem es gemein hinzugeschrieben wird,
sodass es sozusagen die Fortsetzung von Politik mit anderen Mitteln ist.
Klausewitz.
Klausewitz, das war es genau. Klassiker, ne?
Mir wurde ja gesagt, dass Tim ist so der Godfather auf deutsche Podcasts und
Klausewitz ist so der Godfather auf Strategic Studies und eben Kriegswissenschaften.
Also Karl von Klausewitz hat es gesagt.
Okay, muss ich mir auch nochmal so einen Satz einfallen lassen,
den alle die ganze Zeit zitieren.
Ja, also sie ist so, also,
Linus war so ein bisschen skeptisch, als ich irgendwie mit dem Thema ankamen
und gesagt haben, lass mal über Krieg reden.
Das ist halt genau der Punkt, ja.
Da ist der Tisch.
Kann ich verstehen.
Blame me.
Kann ich auch verstehen und ich habe auch selber da jetzt einen anderen Zugang
gefunden, weil ich ja jetzt selber seit Beginn des Krieges oder der neuen Inversion,
vor zweieinhalb Jahren von Russland in die Ukraine das selber jetzt auch begleite
und mich selber dadurch weil ich mit den Themen vertiefe.
Ich mache das halt auch einfach nur so als Coping-Mechanismus eigentlich.
Also wie auch bei Corona. Ich muss dann immer hinterher forschen und alles ganz
genau wissen, weil sonst fühle ich mich da auch so ein bisschen unsicher.
Und ich glaube, kaum ein Thema,
den Leuten mehr Angst als das. Man hat das ja auch gemerkt, wie so eine kleine
Schockwelle auch durchs Land ging und dann hatten wir halt irgendwie Zeitenwende-Verkündungen,
wobei ich nicht den Eindruck habe, dass da viel passiert ist seitdem.
Trotzdem merkt man ja schon, dass sich ein bisschen was ändert.
Wie nimmst du denn so die Gesellschaft jetzt mal speziell auch in Deutschland
wahr, in der aktuellen Situation, in ihrem Verhältnis zu Krieg an sich,
der ja so ein bisschen gestört ist, wie wir alle wissen und auch dem Krieg im Besonderen?
Also es hat sich schon wirklich sehr, sehr viel getan. Ich sollte dazu sagen,
ich bin ja Deutsche, ich habe ein Deutschland-Abi gemacht, habe aber zum Beispiel
nie in Deutschland studiert.
Ich bin direkt nach dem Abi ins Ausland gegangen und habe seitdem,
das ist jetzt auch schon fast 20 Jahre her, nicht mehr länger in Deutschland gelebt.
Habe aber immer zur deutschen Sicherheitsverteidigungspolitik gearbeitet.
Das ist halt interessant, als ich so ein bisschen einen Insider-Outsider irgendwie,
Sicht hatte und die meiste Zeit meines Lebens habe ich dann eben in England
oder in Frankreich verbracht, die ja irgendwie ähnlich sind Deutschland gegenüber,
also es sind auch wie die großen europäischen Länder, aber gerade eben bei Sicherheit,
Militär, Verteidigung einfach eine andere Sichtweise haben.
Das ist nicht eine bessere, das ist eine andere, die natürlich historisch geprägt ist.
Und dadurch ist mir immer so klar geworden, wie, also zumindest wie singulär,
wie ungewöhnlich der deutsche Ansatz zu Sicherheits- und Verteidigungspolitik
und zu Militär generell ist.
Weil es einfach so ist, dass wir uns wirklich,
meines Erachtens der Illusion hingegeben haben, seit 89 und seit dem Fall der Mauer,
dass Krieg und militärische Auseinandersetzung und Machtpolitik eine Sache der
Vergangenheit ist. Und ich sage das...
Natürlich!
Natürlich. Fantastisch. Stimmt nur nicht.
Ja, war gut.
Und das ist im Übrigen, das ist natürlich auch mein Problem,
denn ich mag diese Illusion auch und es macht natürlich auch nicht so Spaß,
den Leuten zu sagen, sorry, was wir uns da so schön eingeredet haben, stimmt nicht.
Ist aber meines Erachtens so und ich sage das auch als jemand,
die ja genau diese Generation ist. Also ich bin 87 geboren, das heißt,
ich bin 100 Prozent diese Generation, ich kenne gar nichts anderes.
Es war halt so diese Überlegung, geopolitischer Wettbewerb, vor allen Dingen
geopolitischer Wettbewerb, der in irgendeiner Weise militärisch ausgefochten
wird, das ist einfach von gestern.
Darüber sind wir weg. Das haben wir jetzt verstanden, dass das Blödsinn ist.
Der Zweite Weltkrieg hat es uns gezeigt, der Kalte Krieg sowieso.
Das beste System des offenen Liberalismus hat gewonnen und zieht jetzt mit der
Globalisierung seinen Siegeszug durch die Welt an.
Und das sah ja auch in den 90ern echt so aus. Die EU wurde immer größer und
alle wollten, wie wir werden.
Und wir Deutschen haben das ganz besonders internalisiert, weil wir gesagt haben,
jetzt guckt mal, wir haben zwar so viel Mist gemacht in unserer Geschichte,
aber wir sind auch wiederum die Ersten, die genau das verstanden haben.
Und wir gehen jetzt quasi mit leuchtendem Beispiel voran.
Wir sind die Erleuchteten und wir verstehen, dass ihr mit euren Panzern und
Militär da einfach von gestern seid.
Wir haben die Mauer eingerissen und seitdem wird nur noch getanzt in Berlin.
So in etwa. Und das ist eine superschöne Illusion. Das war ja auch, wie gesagt,
nicht komplett falsch, als dass wir ja tatsächlich nach 89 echt fast 30 Jahre,
drei Dekaden ziemlichen, also relativen Frieden zumindest eben auf dem großen
Level hatten, geopolitische Ruhe, politische Ruhe.
Es hat sich geopolitisch sehr viel entwickelt in eine Richtung,
die wir quasi positiv fanden.
Der Punkt ist nur, erstens haben wir ausgeblendet, dass wir uns diese ganze
Attitüde leisten konnten, weil auch während dieser 30 Jahre vor allen Dingen
andere für unsere Sicherheit gerade standen und die garantiert haben,
nämlich die USA und die NATO, also die anderen haben quasi gesagt, wir passen auf euch aus.
Und zweitens war es halt eine Illusion, weil dieser schöne Pause von der Geschichte halt temporär war.
Und das hätten wir früher sehen müssen. Ich finde das okay, wenn man in den
90ern und in den 2000ern das irgendwie noch geglaubt hat und Wandel durch Handel
und so weiter, aber 2008 Georgien, 2014 Ukraine etc.
Etc. Da hätte man halt einfach früher merken müssen, okay, war halt doch nur eine Illusion.
Und dem haben wir uns jetzt hingegeben und das haben wir eben sehr auch kultiviert zu sagen,
Militärbä und das ist alles irgendwie schlecht und wir haben im Zuge dessen
auch sehr viele so grundsätzliche Wahrheiten der Sicherheits- und Verteidigungspolitik
aktiv vergessen und verlernt.
Zum Beispiel eben so Dinge wie, wer den Frieden will, sollte sich auf den Krieg vorbereiten.
Abschreckung, um eine wirksame Abschreckung zu haben, damit eben Kriege gar
nicht erst stattfinden, braucht man eben auch eigene Fähigkeiten.
Also sowas, das haben wir irgendwie komplett weggelassen.
Und das ist Teil der Misere, die wir jetzt haben. Das ist auch nicht ein rein deutsches Problem.
Ich habe es jetzt sehr in Deutschland festgemacht, weil sich das da so sehr kristallisiert hat.
Das war auch in anderen europäischen Ländern ein Thema.
Aber ja, das ist so ein bisschen die Situation, wie ich sie quasi gesehen habe
und darüber habe ich auch sehr viel geschrieben, eben vor der Zeitenwende und dann kam eben der 24.
Februar und ich hatte wirklich den Eindruck, dass das für viele Deutsche ein...
Ja, ein Schock, ein Erweckungserlebnis, ein Erwachen.
Ich fand auch Annalena Baerbock da zum Beispiel sehr interessant,
die wirklich gesagt hat, wir wachen heute in einer neuen Welt auf,
was natürlich auf der einen Seite stimmt, auf der anderen Seite musste man halt
sagen, naja, eigentlich hätten wir halt schon länger aufwachen müssen.
Aber sei es drum, also wir sind in dieser neuen Welt aufgewacht und viele Menschen
sehen jetzt Verteidigungspolitik und Militär zum gewissen Grad schon mit einem
anderen Auge, also diese grundsätzliche Ablehnung,
die ich teilweise bemerkt habe,
erlebe ich so nicht mehr.
Gut, teilweise ist sie dann auch richtig laut geworden, aber so das Gros der
Menschen hat, glaube ich, wieder so ein bisschen verstanden,
ah, das ist zwar alles doof, aber wir müssen uns damit auseinandersetzen und
vielleicht macht es doch Sinn, wenn die Bundeswehr irgendwie ein bisschen was
kann und vielleicht ist es nicht so eine gute Idee, wenn irgendwie nur die Guten
abrüsten und die andere Seite stärker wird.
Aber gleichzeitig ist, was ich gerade beschrieben habe, schon wirklich sehr,
sehr tief verwurzelt und alle hoffen wir doch insgeheim irgendwie,
dass wir möglichst bald wieder zu diesem Normal zurückkehren können,
was wir eben auch so als normal.
Wie gesagt, gerade so die Millennials normal internalisiert haben.
Und ich will das auch, aber das gibt es nicht mehr.
Denn das ist nicht die geopolitische Welt, auf die wir in den nächsten Dekaden zusteuern.
Und das ist einfach falsch und unklug, jetzt zu sagen, also wenn dieser Krieg
erstmal vorbei ist, dann können wir jetzt aber auch aufhören mit diesem ganzen Militärgerede.
Fände ich super. Ich will auch wirklich lieber Kindergärten bauen als Panzer.
Aber ich habe vor allen Dingen eigentlich auch lieber die Panzer,
die dann die Kindergärten beschützen.
Und das ist so die Problematik, dass wir einfach uns, glaube ich,
noch nicht wahr geworden sind, dass sich die Welt wirklich grundlegend verändert hat.
Das ist nicht nur Russland, das ist auch Russland. Russland ist spezifisch für
uns in Europa ein Problem.
Das ist auch China, es sind viele Entwicklungen, es ist die USA,
die sich von Europa abkehrt.
All das kommt zusammen und wir leben da leider in einer neuen Welt,
in der alten Welt, wie du es immer titulieren willst, aber eben in einer Welt,
in der dieses Normal von Post 89 leider nicht wiederkommt.
Und wie gesagt, ich bedauere das mit euch und uns allen, aber bin halt der Meinung,
dass wir uns darauf vorbereiten müssen.
Ich habe keine gute Werbung gemacht von wegen amüsant und humorvoll.
Ich weiß, das war jetzt irgendwie sehr...
Naja, ich finde ja, du hast ja total recht und ich meine, ich habe noch ein
bisschen früher geboren als du und ich habe ja auch noch so dieses,
diese andere Gefühlslage auch noch ein bisschen mitbekommen,
durch die Deutschland so durchgegangen ist.
Es war ja auch diese Zeit des Kalten Kriegs in den 80er Jahren,
das ist ja heute auch schwer vermittelbar, was für ein Selbstverständnis wir so in der Jugend hatten.
Diese allgegenwärtige Gefahr, dieses Morgen kann es losgehen und die Atomraketen
regnen so in Deutschland als erstes nieder.
Man war ja quasi so mitten die Frontlinie, die Gedachte und die Angst vor dem
Atomkrieg war ja im Speziellen dann nochmal groß, ob das jetzt tatsächlich stattgefunden
hätte oder nicht, aber es war auf jeden Fall klar,
wo so die Demarkationslinie läuft und dass man sich da drin befindet.
Dann kamen halt diese 90er Jahre mit der Maueröffnung, das war natürlich dann
wirklich auch die totale Befreiung und wahrscheinlich.
Also die Love Parade wäre nicht so gut gewesen ohne die Geschichte davor,
weil dann war ja nur noch Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen, das war ja tatsächlich
das Motto der ersten Love Parade, da drückte sich schon eine ganze Menge drin aus.
Trotzdem, diese Verdrängung ist definitiv in der deutschen Seele drin,
weil es ja auch viel mit Schuld zu tun hat.
Weil es ja auch so dieses so, nee, wir sind jetzt die mit dem Frieden.
Das ist ja so unser Brand jetzt so und wir machen jetzt Sicherheitspolitik,
machen wir so aus der Brieftasche heraus.
Das passt schon irgendwie mit unseren Buddies in Amerika. Und ja,
das ist halt jetzt klar, dass wir da auf einen anderen Weg langsam reinsehen und es schmerzt.
Man merkt richtig, wie es an allen reibt und man Schwierigkeiten hat,
sich da sozusagen auf diesen Weg zu begeben.
Aber ich finde, das findet definitiv statt.
Und eben auch mit Technik.
Und teilweise ja auch wirklich sehr, sehr öffentlich. Also da will ich jetzt
auch mal eine Lanze brechen zum Beispiel.
Also ich habe das erlebt, finde ich, gerade bei den Grünen, die eigentlich wirklich
seit der Zeitenwende recht öffentlich da so einen,
Lernprozess klingt irgendwie so nach, jetzt haben wir dem was beigebracht,
sondern so ein Entwicklungsprozess auch hatten und gesagt haben,
wir ändern gewisse von unseren Positionen aufgrund von sich verändernden Realitäten.
Und das finde ich immer echt einen sehr guten politischen Ansatz.
Weil so muss es ja sein. Es ist ja absolut gut, Ideale zu haben.
Es ist ja absolut gut, die Vorstellungen zu haben.
Aber die Idee ist eben, wenn sich die Welt ändert, ändere ich mich damit.
Und dann machen wir das halt.
Ja, Ulrike, ich kann nur sagen, vielen, vielen Dank für das Teilen deiner Erlebniswelt.
Man kann dich hören im Sicherheitshalber-Podcast und auch im Fernsehen eigentlich
drauf und runter die ganze Zeit, oder?
Also jetzt wahrscheinlich sind im Raum so fünf Leute, die die Sicherheitspolitik
interessiert. Jetzt mache ich es noch kleiner. Ich podcaste nämlich auch auf
Französisch zu den selben Themen.
Also für die, die Sicherheitspolitik machen wollen und Französisch können,
können auch Collimateur hören.
Collimateur, mit Kask et la Plume. Was macht der Podcast?
Das ist ein nicht unähnliches Format, wie Sicherheitshalber auf Französisch.
Etwas vielleicht etwas seriöser, etwas akademischer.
Also ganz ein bisschen weniger gelacht, aber da geht es eben,
und auch vielleicht noch ein bisschen größer geopolitischer Sicherheitspolitik
als Verteidigungspolitik, aber die Idee ist letztendlich dieselbe.
Habe ich auch ganz tolle Mitstreiter und genau, Für die dann zwei Leute im Saal,
die sich interessieren für das Thema und Französisch können,
das würde mich nochmal ganz besonders freuen.
Mich überrascht gar nichts bei dieser Community. Es gibt immer von allem mehr,
als man denkt. Ulrike, vielen Dank.
Danke für die Einladung.
Dein Applaus.
Bei unserer Community rechne ich übrigens eher damit, dass sie jetzt französisch
lernen und den Podcast hören.
Und jodeln. Und jodeln.
Französisch jodeln.
Sie ist Juristin und hat sich bis zur Oberstaatsanwältin bei der Staatsanwaltschaft Köln qualifiziert.
Als solche hat sie sich unter anderem aber vor allem ausgiebig Vielen Dank.
Was soll ich jetzt noch sagen? Herzlich willkommen, Anne Brohecker.
Vielen, vielen Dank.
Ja, vielen Dank für die Einladung. Ich freue mich, hier zu sein.
Da habe ich stundenlang an diesem Text gearbeitet.
Ja, also für die paar Leute, die noch nicht ganz auf der Spur sind.
Sie sind hauptschuldig im Bereich der Verfolgung der Wirtschaftskriminalität in Deutschland,
insbesondere was den Cum-Ex-Skandal geht und sind jetzt Geschäftsführerin bei
der Bürgerbewegung Finanzwende geworden.
Und ja, das war für uns Anlass genug, Sie einzuladen und wir freuen uns natürlich
sehr, dass das geklappt hat. Ganz toll.
Ja, vielen Dank. Ich freue mich, hier zu sein.
Wie kommt man, wie kommt man?
Du musst uns noch was einfallen. Hast du was vorbereitet? Ich würde gerne,
bevor wir auf diese ganze,
auf diese böse Welt kommen, mit der Sie so viel zu tun haben,
würde ich gerne mal ein bisschen nochmal erfahren, was eigentlich so Ihr Werdegang
ist in diesem ganzen Zusammenhang.
Also ich weiß, Sie haben irgendwie Recht studiert und dann relativ schnell auch
den Weg in die Staatsanwaltschaft gefunden. Was war denn so Ihre persönliche
Motivation, überhaupt so einen Weg einzutreten?
Was haben Sie für ein Verhältnis zu Recht?
Ja, also das war gar nicht meine erste Wahl, lustigerweise. Eigentlich wollte
ich gar nicht Jura studieren, sondern ich habe auch mit etwas anderem angefangen, nämlich mit Musik.
Ich habe als Jugendliche immer ganz viel Musik gemacht.
Jodeln?
Eigentlich, ne, Judeln ist mir irgendwie entgangen, aber alles mögliche andere,
auch mehrere Instrumente gespielt, ich wollte auch eigentlich so Orchester oder
wie auch immer, habe mich dann aber schlussendlich für Lehramt entschieden und
habe das genau ein Semester durchgehalten,
weil uns dann im ersten Semester gesagt wurde, diese Republik braucht nie wieder
Lehrer und das haben die uns so halbstündlich gesagt.
Und dann habe ich mit der Hälfte, der Anfänger, da haben wir wieder aufgehört,
weil wir dachten, naja, Lärm ist man natürlich sehr eingeschränkt,
dann ist man doch lange da unterwegs und kann hinterher nur Nachhilfe geben,
so wurde uns das damals gesagt, also wir sollten alle wieder aufhören.
Habe ich dann auch gemacht und da ich ja die ganze Zeit immer gedacht habe,
ich mache irgendwas mit Musik, was auch immer, habe ich dann mich kurz am Kopf
gekratzt und gedacht, was mache ich jetzt?
Mathe ist nicht so meins, also BWL war da nichts für mich und natürlich Jura
passt ja eigentlich immer.
Okay, zweiter Bildungsweg. Welches Instrument haben Sie denn gespielt?
Klavierung, Pferdflöte.
Oh ja, okay. Es sind uns wahrscheinlich großartige Konzerte entgangen,
aber den Tausch nehmen wir.
Und dann, wenn ich das richtig sehe, also diesem Studium der Rechtswissenschaft
folgte dann aber mehr oder weniger direkt der Marsch in die Behörde.
Also es war dann sozusagen auch sofort der Start.
War das denn auch nur so, weil es woanders nicht geklappt hat oder war das eine
bewusste Entscheidung?
Nee, es ging auch in die Richtung. Also tatsächlich muss man ähnlich wie beim
Lehramt auch dann nochmal so ein Referendariat machen,
also macht zwei Staatsexamen und das zweite ist dann davor gelagert,
wird man durch alle Stationen geschleust,
also ist man bei Gericht, man bei der Staatsanwaltschaft und auch ganz viel
bei Anwälten und das fand ich dann irgendwie alles sehr desillusionierend,
also nichts davon konnte mich jetzt so richtig packen.
Ich muss auch sagen, als ich da bei der Staatsanwaltschaft war,
als Referendar, habe ich nicht viel mitgekriegt.
Also das war eine riesen Staatsanwaltschaft. Der Mensch hatte gar keine Zeit für mich.
Ich habe da nicht so viel mitgekriegt und hatte gar nicht so einen Eindruck.
Was ich super fand, wir sind sofort, auch im Referendariat schon,
kriegt man da eine Robe um und muss los.
Also ich saß dann an meinem ersten Tag da sozusagen mit der Robe und saß dann
in einem Saal mit einer Richterin, die auch ihren ersten Tag hatte.
Also wir waren die Profis da. Ich musste auch mal zwischendurch ein bisschen
blättern, wie das alles so funktioniert.
Aber das fand ich schon spannend. Und alle anderen Sachen, insbesondere sämtliche
Stationen bei den Rechtsanwälten, haben mir eigentlich überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Und mir wurde da immer gespiegelt, dass ich da auch nicht so besonders talentiert für bin.
Da wurde nämlich immer gesagt, Frau Brolka, Ihnen fehlt das wirtschaftliche
Denken, weil ich habe dann immer gesagt, aber ich muss doch den Mandanten beraten
und wenn ich jetzt doch geguckt habe und das hat gar keine Aussicht auf Erfolg,
dann muss ich das dem noch sagen.
Dann sagten die so, nee, nee, dann muss man dem natürlich nicht sagen,
ist ja ja nicht mehr unser Mandant.
Also war ich da jetzt nicht so erfolgreich drin und das war auch nichts,
wäre auch nichts für mich gewesen.
Ich habe auch lustigerweise eine Station gemacht bei einem Anwalt,
der Wirtschaftsstrafrecht gemacht hat und das fand ich ganz besonders furchtbar,
weil damals, da war bei der Staatsanwaltschaft Bochum in dem Bereich und die
Bochumer waren immer schon sehr dafür bekannt, dass die Leute sofort in Haft nahmen.
Also die waren immer total Attacke und dann war dann unser Alltag so,
also der Mandant saß in Haft, die Frau heulte und er sagt dann,
okay, wo sind die Konten und dann ist der 14 Tage durch ganz Europa gereist,
nach Zürich und sonst was, hat das Geld zusammengekratzt, Du bist dann mit zwei
Koffern zur Staatsanwaltschaft, hast da hingelegt und dann war der Fall zu Ende.
Und dann dachte ich, das ist ja irgendwie komisch. Also ich hatte währenddessen
geguckt, so Börsengesetz und so, brauchten wir gar nicht. Gab nie einen Prozess.
Und das fand ich auch irgendwie unethisch. Also jedenfalls war das,
sag ich am Ende, so ein bisschen ratlos.
Und dann war ich noch bei einer letzten Wahlstation, das kann man sich dann
aussuchen, war ich bei Amnesty International, weil ich dachte,
ja, das ist bestimmt eine intrinsisch motivierte Geschichte, das finde ich super.
Ja, war dann in der Praxis auch anders. Ist jetzt schon lange her.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das heute ist. Damals waren das nur wenig Hauptamtliche.
Die kamen mir vor wie Beamte.
Und die Ehrenamtlichen, die waren sehr engagiert, aber irgendwie hat mich das
jetzt auch nicht so gereizt. Und dann musste ich aber irgendwas machen.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, naja, das mit der Robe damals, das war schon gut bei
der Staatsanwaltschaft, mache ich das mal.
Also war mir so eine Modeentscheidung.
Ja, fand ich auch. Ich war ja immer klein und blond und so eine Robe,
das macht ja schon was her.
Okay, verstehe.
Das, ja, damit habe ich jetzt nicht gerechnet.
Und die Vertiefung auf Wirtschaftsrecht, die hatte sich aber schon vorher irgendwie...
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Auch nicht?
Nee, also mit Wirtschaft hatte ich gar nichts am Mut, habe ich auch nicht studiert
oder so, hat mich auch nie interessiert.
Also deswegen kann ich gut verstehen, wenn Leute sagen, das interessiert mich nicht.
Das hat mich auch ganz lange überhaupt nicht interessiert, weil ich auch die
Trachweite gar nicht begriffen habe.
Also ich habe mich immer für gesellschaftspolitische Themen interessiert,
auch weil meine Mutter war Politik- und Sowilehrerin und da habe ich immer schon
als Kind ihre ganzen Bücher gelesen und so.
Ich fand das super spannend, politische Themen und sozialpolitische Themen,
aber ich habe damals nicht begriffen, ganz lange Zeit nicht,
dass es verdammt relevant ist, wo das Geld ist.
Und ich habe immer gedacht, das ist irgendwie so, ich interessiere mich nicht
für Geldvermehrung, das ist nicht meine Welt, aber ich habe eigentlich die Relevanz
des Ganzen lange Zeit gar nicht erkannt.
Ich habe das dann aber erst gesehen, als ich bei der Staatsanwaltschaft dann
da schlichtweg eingesetzt wurde.
Also das ist eine Behörde, die schiebt halt ihr Personal dahin,
wo Lücken sind und da war irgendwann in einer Steuerstrafrechtsabteilung,
musste jemand hin und das war dann ich und ich habe auch ein bisschen gestrampelt,
ich wollte das nicht, Ich wollte lieber dahin, wo alle wollten,
so organisierte Kriminalität und da, wo ich das jetzt dachte, wo es spannend ist.
Da will man hin?
Ja, da will man hin. Weil das eigentlich spannend ist.
Spannend. Organisierte Kriminalität.
In Deutschland werden die Staatsanwältinnen, die die organisierte Kriminalität,
verfolgen, noch nicht mit einer ganzen Brücke gesprengt, aber will man sich
wirklich mit denen anlegen? Also haben sie ja dann am Ende gemacht.
Aber Ja, also ich sage mal, es gibt es natürlich auch von bis.
Also normal, wenn man eine organisierte Kriminalität macht, dann hat man auch mal einen Brecherbann.
Also das ist jetzt nicht immer so die ausländische, italienische Mafia.
Ja, aber natürlich, ja, das gibt es.
Also, dass Kollegen auch Polizeischutz kriegen, das ist so das Schlimmste,
was einem passieren kann als Staatsanwalt, wenn man wirklich in so einer Gefährdungslage
ist, weil da leiden alle drunter, die ganze Familie auch.
Man kann sich nicht mal frei bewegen, die Wohnung wird umgebaut.
Und wir hatten mal eine Kollegin, die hat Cybercrime gemacht.
Und hat da um Darkneck ermittelt und war ja irgendwie einer Gruppe unterwegs,
die gar nicht so groß war, aber die waren extrem gefährlich.
Und das war eine ganz junge Kollegin noch und die hat zehn Jahre lang Polizeischutz
gekriegt. Das war ganz furchtbar.
Wow, echt wegen Cybercrime, krass.
Ja, also Cybercrime, ja, das war in unserer Abteilung im Grunde genommen die
Banden, die halt über solche Mechanismen agierten wie Darkpools und so weiter.
Und da war es eben, war so eine Gefährdungslage und das hat auch noch ausgerechnet
eine junge Kollegin getroffen, das war schon schwierig.
Wie hat sich das geäußert?
Sie hat Morddrohungen bekommen und die, wenn das, also das kriegt man schon
mal als Staatsanwalt, das ist jetzt nicht immer ernst zu nehmen,
manchmal reden ja auch Leute einfach, wenn sie auf Twitter oder auch so mal
im Gerichtssaal, aber das ist jetzt nicht immer ernst zu nehmen, sondern dann,
gibt es wirklich eine formelle Prüfung, also Also dann gucken sich das Experten
an von der Polizei, wie man eingeschätzt wird. Das ist so eine Gefährderanalyse.
Und bei ihr war das dann so, dass es ernst zu nehmen ist. Und deswegen hat sie
wirklich lange, lange Zeit Polizeischutz bekommen.
Also durfte sich überhaupt nicht bewegen. Man kann sich das jetzt mal so als
junger Mensch vorstellen, wenn man abends nicht mal einfach rauskam oder nicht
mal eben zum Bäcker, sondern jedes Mal erst anrufen muss, dass da ein Auto kommt und einen begleitet.
Und auch das permanente Gefühl, dass man...
Das ist krass. Da ist eigentlich jede Freiheit genommen.
Ja, also das war auch so. Sie war eine starke Person oder ist eine starke Persönlichkeit,
hat das gut verkraftet. Und irgendwann, nach ein paar Jahren,
hat es sich dann auch gegeben.
Aber das muss man natürlich auch erstmal wieder für sich verarbeiten,
dass jetzt die Polizei sagt, wir meinen jetzt, das ist jetzt nicht mehr so.
Wenn man ja zehn Jahre lang damit gelebt hat, dass man also jederzeit angegriffen werden kann.
Also das ist schon hart und das trifft eben auch Kollegen, allerdings kommt
das nicht allzu oft vor, sondern normalerweise, ich hatte das ja vorhin so flapsig
gesagt, ist es insofern, weil man da an großen Verfahren arbeitet,
auch längerfristig mit der Polizei
zusammenarbeitet, also die ganzen Ermittlungen auch zusammen plant,
mit dann dabei ist, mit bei den Einsätzen dabei ist und sich da quasi viel besser
einbringen kann und viel enger auch an den ganzen Dingen dabei ist,
als man das zum Beispiel in anderen Bereichen der Staatsanwaltschaft ist und
man nur am Schreibtisch sitzt.
Deswegen ist das schon grundsätzlich eine Abteilung, wo alle hinwollen und das wollte ich auch.
Und Steuern, so typisch so leidenhafte Sicht.
Steuerklang für mich jetzt mal eher so unspannend.
Endlich kann ich sagen, ich finde das auch nicht spannend.
Also mir ging das mal so, aber das ist mittlerweile auch anders.
Wir zahlen unsere Steuern gerne, Frau Bräu.
Ich finde das sexy. So, und was, okay, aber dann haben Sie Ihr Schicksal sozusagen
angenommen und dann war es halt die Wirtschaftskriminalitätsabteilung.
Was kommt da so auf den Tisch normalerweise?
Ja, das ist dann schon richtig Bannkriminalität. Also Umsatzsteuerkarussell
ist eine ganz bekannte Masche. Das sind so Kreisgeschäfte mit Waren,
wo es auch nicht um Handel geht, sondern es ist alles vorher abgesprochen und so.
Und dann geht es auch nur darum, dass man sich eine Steuer zurückzahlen lässt,
die man vorher nicht gezahlt hat. Das ist eigentlich das Gleiche in Grün,
wie diese Aktienkreisgeschäfte.
Also das ist ganz weit verbreitet und es ist auch wirklich schwer,
dem beizukommen. Da geht uns auch unglaublich viel Geld verloren.
Das war so das Erste. Ich hatte auch eine Softwarefirma, die behauptet hat,
sie würde ihre Leistungen eher so im Ausland verbringen und ihre Gewinne eben
versucht hat, über diesen Mechanismus ins Ausland zu verbringen.
Das war schon das erste Mal, wo ich sehr viel Rechtshilfe gemacht habe,
sehr viel mit ausländischen Staaten zusammengearbeitet habe.
Und da kam man auch gleich mit der Lobby in Kontakt, denn der Bruder von diesem
Täter, von dem Haupttäter, der die Firma gehörte,
der war praktischerweise Vorsteher des Finanzamts, das für seinen Bruder zuständig war.
Und das hat dann natürlich auch nicht so richtig streng hingeguckt.
Der saß teilweise auch im Aufsichtsrat.
Da habe ich auch mal durchsucht dann.
Das hat mich der Mensch mit den Worten begrüßt. Sie trauen sich was.
Ja, das war, dann Subventionsbetrug hatte ich, das war auch sehr politisch, das war auf Rügen.
Man weiß, wer da so seinen Wahlkreis hatte auf Rügen und da gab es dann auch
jedes Jahr den Innovationspreis,
aus dem Kanzleramt damals in der Zeit und diese, ja, da hatten wir aber den
Eindruck oder hat sich auch hinterher so rausgestellt, dass das eben Subventionsbetrug war.
Und als ich dann da durchsucht habe, da liefen dann auch die Drähte heiß.
Also die, die da Geld gegeben haben, die fühlten sich dann überhaupt gar nicht
geschädigt und haben dann bei der Staatsanwaltschaft angerufen und haben gesagt,
also was macht ihr denn da? Geht da mal wieder weg.
Wir wollen, dass das alles so bleibt. Da hatte ich ja mal einen Vorgesetzten,
der da sehr entspannt war und das auch sehr gut abgefedert hat.
Von daher öffnete sich da eine Welt, die mir vorher gar nicht bekannt war.
Also was da für eine Kriminalität am Start ist,
wie hoch jeweils die Summen sind, wie gut abgesichert das ist,
eben durch Connections und durch Vernetzungen und wie schwer es dann eine Staatsanwaltschaft
hat, auch in diesem Bereich zu ermitteln.
Also da freuen sich die Vorgesetzten nicht.
Was macht das so schwer?
Ja, die Behörden sind an der Stelle sehr schwach aufgestellt.
Also es war durchgängig so, jetzt nicht nur bei Cum-Ex, vorher auch,
dass wir viel zu wenig waren. Also es war immer viel zu wenig Ermittler.
Teilweise sind Ermittlungen daran gescheitert, dass wir zum Beispiel sagten,
also wir müssen Telefonüberwachung machen.
Und dann sagten sie, naja, bei der Steuerverwaltung haben wir gar kein Apparat.
Dann sagte ich, ich habe kein Apparat. Dann haben wir nicht.
Dann habe ich halt erstmal geschaut, dass ich bei der Polizei dann nachfragte,
ob wir vielleicht mal freundlicherweise deren Apparate nutzen durften.
Ist ja auch schon verrückt irgendwie, dass die Steuerverhandlung erst gar nichts hatte.
Dann haben die das aber auch noch nie gemacht. Die konnten das nicht richtig
mit der Technik und dann der Interpretation.
Also war alles irgendwie sehr schwergängig und die Polizei fand das auch nicht
so lustig, dass wir da ihre Apparate nutzten.
Also war alles immer irgendwie so Mangelverwaltung und schwierig Und auf der
anderen Seite hat man dann eben so eine Täterschaft sitzen,
die hochprofessionell ist, die natürlich alle Ressourcen der Welt haben,
bestellen sich sofort ganz teure Anwaltskanzleien, erschlagen einen da mit tausend
Seiten Schriftsatz mit goldenem Stempel obendrauf und dem muss man natürlich
dann erstmal was entgegensetzen.
Also das ist ein totales Ungleichgewicht zwischen den Ressourcen,
die der Staat an der Stelle hat oder die er an der Stelle einsetzt und den Ressourcen,
die auf der anderen Seite da sind.
Und warum sind diese Ressourcen so mangelhaft ausgeprägt? Ist das,
weil keiner will oder weil es keiner braucht?
Beides, würde ich denken. Also insgesamt natürlich haben wir in Deutschland
zwar irgendwie sehr viel Beamte, sehr viel Bürokratie, aber wir haben auch viele Doppelstrukturen.
Dadurch, dass wir Föderalismus haben, gibt es vieles doppelt.
Und da sind die Zuständigkeiten schon oft unklar und das führt aus meiner Sicht
irgendwie dazu, dass das jetzt nicht besonders synergiesparend ist,
sondern das sind irgendwie mal viele da, die sich manchmal auch gegenseitig am Füßen stehen.
Das könnte man sicherlich anders organisieren, wenn man denn wollte.
Das Zweite ist, dass schon die ganzen Ausbildungsstrukturen eigentlich auch nicht so sind.
Also weder bei der Polizei noch bei der Staatsanwaltschaft gibt es spezielle
Ausbildungssegmente für diesen Bereich, da geht es schon mit los.
Also auch bei der Polizei gibt es eigentlich kaum Ressourcen für Wirtschaftsstrafrecht
und auch man macht da mal so eine 0 auf 15 Fortbildung, die einem aber natürlich nicht weiterhilft.
Es ist nicht besonders professionell aufgestellt. Das kann man natürlich alles ändern.
Also in einer idealen Welt, wenn man jetzt freie Hand hätte,
ich meine so frei ist man ja nicht, weil wir zum Beispiel diese Doppelstrukturen
haben von Föderalismus, Bund und Land, aber wenn man jetzt sich das alles nochmal
anschauen würde, dann könnte man das natürlich anders organisieren und.
Das ist auch eine Forderung, die ich jetzt aus meiner ganzen Praxis heraus wirklich stellen würde,
dass man für besonders schwerwiegende Fälle bei Wirtschaft strafreit,
wie zum Beispiel Umsatzsteuerkarusselle,
aber eben auch die Cum-Ex- und Cum-Cum-Straftaten, die wirklich unfassbar viel
Schaden verursachen und die auch wirklich sehr schwer zu ermitteln sind,
dass man da Sonderstrukturen schafft, also sprich eine zentrale Stelle.
Dann braucht man nämlich auch nicht mehr irgendwie 300 Leute,
sondern dann hat man da eine Gruppe sitzen, die sich dauerhaft mit dieser Thematik
beschäftigt, die auch Zeit hat, überhaupt mal Kompetenzen aufzubauen.
Also in der Behördenwelt ist alles immer gleich.
Also egal, ob man jetzt irgendwie den kleinen Ladendieb verfolgt oder den großen
Wirtschaftsstraftäter.
Behördenlogik ist oft so, jeder muss alles können und jeder muss dauernd irgendwo
hingeschoben werden können.
Es gibt gar nicht das Bewusstsein dafür, dass es vielleicht auch durchaus sinnvoll
ist, dass man mal sich spezialisiert.
Und das muss man irgendwie aus den Köpfen rauskriegen. Und deswegen,
weil das aber so ist und zwar nicht nur in der Justiz, sondern auch bei der
Polizei und bei der Steuerverhandlung oder in der Finanzverwaltung,
sind die Personalentwicklungskonzepte, also sozusagen wie man so voranschreitet
in seinem Weg als Beamter, die sind so ausgelegt, dass man möglichst überall mal gewesen sein soll.
Also es ist sozusagen Plus für die Karriere, wenn man ganz viel gemacht hat
und es ist total negativ gewesen, wenn man so wie ich 15 Jahre das gleiche macht.
Also ich hatte wirklich dadurch Nachteile in der Benotung und nicht nur ich,
sondern auch viele Kollegen, die dann wirklich teilweise auch da geblieben sind,
obwohl sie wussten, dass sie dann nicht befördert werden.
Und das ist natürlich auch noch total überholt im Grunde genommen,
das hat man nicht gemacht, weil man das aktiv verhindern wollte,
nur man hat es nie im Blick gehabt.
Und das ist sicherlich, warum hatte man das nicht im Blick, das ist sicherlich
damit in Verbindung zu bringen, dass die Gegenseite jetzt auch kein Interesse
daran hat, durch die Weltgeschichte zu laufen und zu sagen, wir rauben euch übrigens aus,
sondern das wird natürlich auch abgeschottet.
Das ist wie organisierte Kriminalität, die sieht man ja auch nicht.
Man geht ja auch in China-Restaurant und weiß nicht, dass dahinter Schubsgeld-Erpressungen
stehen oder dass da Geld gewaschen wird. Das sieht man ja alles nicht.
Und das ist eben im Wirtschaftssegment auch nicht anders. das.
Und deswegen ist beides. Also Behörden haben das lange Zeit übersehen,
haben auch sich oft nicht zugetraut, überhaupt sich mit der Thematik zu beschäftigen.
Also das ist auch etwas, was mich furchtbar aufregt, dass wir auch bei anderen
Aufsichtsbehörden, zum Beispiel bei der BaFin, die ist ja Bankenregulierer, Bankenaufsicht,
die haben auch eigentlich sehr viel Personal, auch gutes Personal,
aber die haben eigentlich keine Ahnung, was die Banken da so machen.
Und das ist ja schon ein bisschen verstörend.
In der Aufsichtsbehörde würde man sowas ja schon erwarten in gewisser Hinsicht.
Ja, aber ich sage mal, so ist jetzt auch nicht so einfach. Also dieser Wertpapierhandel,
der ist ja schon sehr speziell und es ist sehr einfach,
das Ganze auch nochmal abzuschotten und dem so einen Anstrich der totalen Komplexität
zu geben und damit auch Leute einfach abzuschrecken und sich damit zu beschäftigen.
Und das ist aber, glaube ich, eine ganz unkluhe Entscheidung.
Es wäre da viel sinnvoller, das so zu machen, zum Beispiel wie in UK,
da gibt es auch die Bankenregulierung, da ist FCA.
Und die prüft selber, sie hat sich selber Wertpapier-Händler in ihre Reihen
genommen und die kann dann selber, also die haben das ja selber auf der anderen
Seite vorher gemacht, die haben natürlich ein totales Verständnis dafür,
wo die hingucken müssen.
Ich habe mich auch mehrfach mit denen ausgetauscht und die haben das dann mal
sofort alle verstanden. Die sagten, naja, das kennen wir, das kennen wir und so weiter.
Und wenn man jetzt aber sich vorstellt, hier bei der Deutschen BAföG wird das
nicht so gemacht, sondern die sourcen die Prüfungen aus auf Wirtschaftsprüfungsunternehmen.
Also die geben im Grunde genommen die Kompetenz ab.
Das heißt, erstens gucken sie
dann gar nicht selbst drauf, sondern haben Informationen aus zweiter Hand.
Und zweitens so die Wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaften, die ja auch viel beratend
tätig sind. Die haben oft auch eine Beratungssparte.
Die haben natürlich auch große monetäre Interessen auf Seiten der Banken,
weil sie einfach viele Aufträge für die übernehmen.
Und dann überrascht es einen nicht, dass hinten rauskommt, ach da war nichts.
Und dann sagt die BaFin, naja, dann ist ja gut. Und dann klagen wir an und dann gibt es Ärger.
Oh Mann.
Und wie kommt man, also wie fühlt es sich denn jetzt an, ausgerechnet in diesem
Feld dann zu sagen, gegen alle diese Widrigkeiten, also gegen,
ich tue meiner Karriere nichts Gutes, ich habe nicht die Mittel,
also im Prinzip alles, was die Organisation,
in der ich bin, alles, was die macht, ist im Prinzip dagegen gerichtet,
dass ich jetzt hier weitermache.
Da muss ja irgendetwas, also irgendein Drive muss da ja trotzdem sein,
dass man sagt, ich mach aber jetzt trotzdem.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist meine intrinsische Motivation. Also von außen kam die
Motivation sicherlich nicht, sondern,
das ist etwas, das geht jetzt auch nicht nur mir so, ich hatte auch viele Kollegen
bei der Polizei oder bei der Steuerfahndung, die das auch so hatten,
die auch gesagt haben, das ist ja eine Riesenschweinerei und das können wir
uns auch nicht bieten lassen als Staat.
Also ich meine, die machen sich über uns lustig. Wir haben E-Mails gelesen,
wo wirklich darüber sich lustig gemacht wird, wie doof der deutsche Staat ist
und dass sie da auch noch hier ausgerechnet in Deutschland diese lustige Steuergeheimnisse
haben, das heißt, sie sprechen auch noch nicht mal drüber.
Also das ist wirklich so ein Hohn, der einem da auch entgegenprallte und das
ist natürlich schon etwas, wo einen der Ehrgeiz packt, wenn man dann denkt,
also das wollen wir doch mal sehen, ob wir hier alle dumm und doof sind.
Gut, ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass sich da einige von abschrecken lassen,
aber sie offensichtlich nicht.
Aber dann bleibt ja trotzdem das Ressourcenproblem. Problem.
Also dann stelle ich mir vor...
Kann man dann einfach sagen, ach so, übrigens Chef, ich kümmere mich jetzt nur
noch hier um diesen einen Fall?
Ja, das kann man sagen, da macht man sich keine Freunde mit.
Aber das habe ich dann natürlich auch zunehmend gesagt, das wird jetzt immer
größer und ich brauche unbedingt Ressourcen.
Und das ist einfach in einer Behörde, die wie alle anderen Behörden auch einen
Mangel an Ressourcen haben, natürlich nichts, was da irgendwie auf Gegenliebe stößt.
Ich hatte dann mal insofern auch Glück, zwischenzeitlich hatte ja mal ein Justizminister,
der Herr Biesenbach, da sein Herz für entdeckt und hat auch erkannt,
dass hier das auch eine Riesenschweinerei ist, man da unbedingt gegenhalten muss.
Und in der Phase haben wir sehr viel Personal bekommen bei der Staatsanwaltschaft
Köln und er hat auch, und das finde ich auch, wirklich eine tolle Leistung,
er hat auch mit den anderen Ressorts gesprochen, also mit dem Finanz- und dem Innenressort.
Also dass sie drei Ressorts mal absprechen und sich einig sind,
dass sie wirklich alle drei ihre kaum vorhandenen Personalressourcen bündeln,
also das finde ich schon echt einen tollen politischen Erfolg auch an der Stelle.
Und von daher, das war wirklich super, also da haben wir sowohl mehr Stellen
gekriegt als eben auch auf Seiten der Mittler ist das aufgestockt worden und
das hat uns dann zum Beispiel damals in die Lage versetzt, 14 Banken zu durchsuchen.
Das wäre vorher nicht möglich.
Also Bankraub kennen wir alle. Wie geht Bankdurchsuchen?
Ja, das gibt es auch von bis. So als ich in der Steuerabteilung angefangen habe,
bin ich auf eine Durchsuchung geschickt worden, die damals mein Chef mehr oder
weniger Zähne knirschen, weil die Steuerfahndung unbedingt so genervt hatte.
Na ja, gut, dann machen wir mal irgendwie durchsuchen.
Und dann bin ich da gleich am Anfang irgendwie hingeschickt worden und war dann auch etwas erstaunt.
Ich kam ja aus anderen Bereichen der Kriminalität.
Ich war dann bei einer Bank und bei einer ganz teuren Privatbank,
bin da erstmal so durch knietiefe Teppiche gewartet, vorbei an Kunstwerken.
Und dann wurden wir in einen Raum gebeten, also wir waren brav und haben gewartet,
bis irgendjemand kam und kam dann auch einer und hat uns dann in einen Raum
gebeten und wir standen also in einer Reihe und haben alle Guten Tag gesagt,
mir hat man nicht die Hand gegeben.
Ich war übrigens die einzige Frau da. Das ist ja interessant.
Ich bin übrigens die Leiterin der Ermittlungen, aber Guten Tag auch.
Ja, es hat sich dann geändert, als ich meinen Dienstausweis auf den Tisch gelegt
habe, aber das zeigt auch so ein bisschen die Haltung.
Also die haben es natürlich überhaupt nicht ernst genommen, also wie auch da
standen fünf Männer, angeführt von einer kleinen Frau.
Wir hatten ja auch keine Ermittler dabei. Das heißt, man hat ein nettes Gespräch
geführt, das war irgendwie nach zwei Stunden vorbei und dann sind wir nach Hause
gefahren und mein Chef, also mein damaliger Abteilungsleiter,
der war irgendwie nach Frankfurt gefahren,
da haben sie ihn gar nicht reingelassen und dann hat er gesagt,
naja gut, dann fahre ich wieder zurück.
Also der ist einfach wieder zurückgefahren.
So und dann dachte ich auch so, das ist ja doch irgendwie anders.
Also das kann ja wohl nicht sein. Naja und dann habe ich das dann auch,
als ich selber dann meine eigenen Felder organisiert habe, natürlich anders
gemacht, so wie ich es auch kannte.
Und als ich dann mit Cum-Ex angefangen habe und dann sich die Notwendigkeit
ergab, auch wirklich Banken zu durchsuchen, da hatte ich natürlich auch schon jetzt Erfahrung.
Also auch Erfahrung, wie man große Firmen durchsucht. Also zum Beispiel hatte
ich schon Erfahrung gemacht bei der Softwarefirma.
Da bin ich dann mit meinen Fahrern aufmarschiert. Das waren zwar relativ viele,
aber wir standen da vor so einer stacheldrahtgesicherten Serverfarm.
Ich mit meinem Steuerfahrer.
Das ist ja interessant. Und jetzt? Da habe ich das erste Mal gedacht,
das kann man mit Bord bitte nicht machen.
Wenn wir mit sowas konfrontiert sind, brauchen wir Fachleute.
Seitdem habe ich zum Beispiel immer IT-Fachleute mitgenommen,
die dann wirklich in der Lage waren, da auch wirklich zu gucken, was ist denn da, ne?
Da war Stacheldraht um den Server?
Ja, es war so eine Server-Farm regelrecht. Und da war viel Stacheldraht drum.
Also hochgesichert alles.
Jetzt komme ich ordentlich zu der Frage, wie durchsucht man eine Bank?
Und das war mir dann schon klar, dass wir, wenn wir da nicht nur fragen wollen,
sondern wir wollen da wirklich gucken.
Und da muss man die ja genauso durchsuchen, wie man das machen würde,
wenn man in einer Drogenkriminalität unterwegs ist und eine Wohnung durchsucht.
Das heißt, man muss genügend Leute mitnehmen, dass sie jeden Raum durchsuchen
können. Und die machen auch bitte jede Schublade auf.
Morgens um fünf?
Ja, also um fünf ist in der Bank noch keiner, das ist anders als bei Kundungen.
Aber jedenfalls sind wir dann immer mit 100 oder so etwa dahin,
manchmal auch mehr noch und hatten, wie gesagt, auch schon mit IT-Fachleuten,
also wir haben sowohl nach Papier dann geschaut und zwar überall,
ich habe auch wirklich in den Kellern geguckt zum Beispiel und wir haben zusätzlich
Datengespräche geführt, weil der Trick bei der Bank ist nämlich,
da kommen noch nicht mal IT-Fachleute an die Systeme.
Die sind so geschützt, dass da wirklich der Staat nicht dran kommt.
Und das war mir vorher auch nicht klar. Also wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel ein
Unternehmen durchsucht haben, oder ich sage jetzt mal eine Dönerbude,
was viel häufiger vorkommt, dass man eine Dönerbude durchsucht,
dann hat man den Eindruck, hier stimmt irgendwas nicht, man macht so lustige
Döner-Test-Käufe und beißt da rein und guckt, ob der Fleischanteil da ist.
Und dann hat man anfangs gedacht, und dann geht man rein.
Ja, das ist der Döner-Access-Kauf. So läuft das in der Praxis.
Das machen Steuerfahnder total gerne.
Und deswegen machen wir es auch so routiniert. Naja, aber jedenfalls haben die
den Eindruck, da stimmt irgendwas nicht und dann nehmen die halt die Kasse mit.
Das ist ein Kassenautomat heutzutage und das wird dann irgendwie die Kasse ausgelesen
und so weiter, das Computerprogramm und dann findet man da Schummelsoftware, das gibt es da auch.
Aber das ist möglich, das gibt es bei Banken nicht. Also wir können da nicht
hin und die Banksysteme filzen, sondern das Einzige, was man machen kann,
ist eben zu fragen, wo habt ihr denn eure Daten?
Im Regelfall haben die ihre Daten nicht im Inland, die sind ja auch nicht doof,
sondern die packen die dahin, arbeiten ja heute alle mit Clouds und sonst was,
wo möglichst hohe Schutzrechte sind.
Es gibt eben zum Beispiel in Niederlanden und in Großbritannien gibt es ganz,
ganz, ganz hohe Schutzrechte für alle aus der Branche, also für Steuerberater,
Wirtschaftsprüfer, Rechtsanwälte und irgendwas davon ist man immer in einer Bank beteiligt.
Und das bedeutet dann, das Schutzrechte bedeutet, dass noch nicht mal,
wenn die sich selber strafbar gemacht haben, bekommt man dann die Unterlagen.
Also ich würde das rechtsfreien Raum nennen für diese Branche.
Ja, und da sind die natürlich nicht doof und packen da ihre Daten hin.
Dann steht man da als Ermittler.
Das heißt, man muss jetzt erst mal fragen, wo sind die? Dann sagen die irgendwie
im Ausland. Dann muss man sagen, ja, wo denn?
Dann dauert das manchmal einen Tag mit richtig viel Druck, dass sie sich vielleicht
mal bequem zu sagen, wo die sind. Manche Banken haben das noch nicht mal gemacht.
Aber meistens machen sie es dann, weil sie denken, da kommt die eh nicht dran.
Und dann ist es zum Beispiel sinnvoll, dass man auf einer technischen Ebene
nachfragt, wo sind die denn noch?
Weil die werden ja auch oft nochmal gespiegelt oder sind noch an anderen Stellen,
wo wir vielleicht leichter drankommen.
Und deswegen war diese Phase der Durchsuchungen, das auf dem IT-technischen
Grundlage zu machen, eine ganz entscheidende.
Denn dadurch sind uns ganz viele Dinge, also ganz viele Beweismittel haben wir
durch diese Technikgespräche bekommen. kommen.
Und ich hatte das vorher eben ohne IT-Sachverständige gemacht und da sind,
da ändert das dann so, wo sind die E-Mails, dann sagen die in Amerika.
Und dann sagt der Fahrer, naja, doof, doof das Ganze, kommen wir nicht dran.
Und dann, ja, steht man da.
Aber wenn man eben Fachleute mitbringt, dann können die auf einer technischen
Ebene fragen, dann fragen die nach dem System und wo sind die Schnittstellen und all sowas.
Und so haben wir zum Beispiel mal rausgefunden, dass eine große Institution,
die den Börsenhandel abwickelt, ich darf jetzt nicht sagen welche,
aber so viel gibt es in Deutschland nicht.
Die wirklich immer behauptet hatte, ja, liebe Behörden, das ist alles in Luxemburg,
müsst ihr Rechtshilfe nach Luxemburg machen.
Und Luxemburg ist ein Staat, der seine Banken sehr schützt, da kommt man kaum dran.
Und dann haben wir bei der Durchsuchung durch die IT-Fachgespräche festgestellt,
dass dem nicht so ist, sondern die waren tatsächlich auch im Inland.
Und das haben die dann festgestellt. Und dann habe ich den Vorstand einberufen
und habe gesagt, also, ich mache mir jetzt so ein bisschen Sorgen um die Außendarstellung.
Wir haben jahrelang gesagt, das wäre in Luxemburg.
Da müssen wir jetzt feststellen, dann gäbe es doch Schnittstellen nach Deutschland.
Und die werden noch hier.
Ja, und dann fiel schon das Wort Datensee und dann am nächsten Tag kam der CIO,
also der für IT zuständige Vorstand auf mich zu und dachte, ja,
er hätte jetzt auch gelernt,
dass Maschinen miteinander kommunizieren.
Und dass die Luxemburger Maschine mit der Deutschen kommuniziert.
Und dass deswegen die Daten auch in Deutschland werden.
Ist das Land, das ist verloren.
Mit der Nummer ist er wahrscheinlich lange Zeit ganz gut durchgegangen.
Ja, das habe ich auch. Und dann?
Dann habe ich gesagt, jetzt her mit den Daten. und dann haben die gesagt,
das geht nicht, da sind viel zu viele.
Wir haben die nicht lesen.
Das ist aber eine super gute Ansage, weil vorher, als ich noch keine ITler mit
hatte, war das nämlich so.
Da war ich zum Beispiel mal in einer Bank gewesen und dann haben die gesagt,
okay, diese ganzen Daten liegen auf einem Kuhlaufwerk oder was auch immer.
Und dann war das zu groß. Dann konnten wir das nicht spiegeln.
Und das war natürlich ein bisschen peinlich, dass so eine Behörde da aufschlägt
und sagt, jetzt haben die uns schon gesagt, wo die Daten sind,
können wir nicht mitnehmen.
Also das waren alles so Ereignisse, wo ich gesagt habe, da brauche ich Sachverstand.
Und das war jetzt hier näher. Da haben die gesagt, okay, die Daten sind hier,
aber es sind viel zu viele.
Und dann haben wir die ITler eben dazu gebeten und so weiter und dann haben
die gesagt, nö, kein Problem.
Petarbeit, kriegen wir hin.
War denn das schwierig, gute ITler zu bekommen?
Also kommen die dann aus dem eigenen Behördenbereich oder sind das Externe? Das waren Externe.
Ja, das war eine Gruppe von Leuten, die schon länger auch mit Behörden zusammenarbeiten,
die hatten auch viel Erfahrung,
haben oft für Staatsanwaltschaften gemacht, das war super, sie kannten sich
auch gut mit den ganzen Abläufen und so weiter aus, aber waren einfach fachlich super top.
Also gerade die wirklich ausgesprochen anspruchsvollen Datengespräche zu den
Systemen der Banken, also die hätte man wirklich ohne diese Fachexpertise nicht führen können.
Und die sind bald die Wände hochgegangen, die Banken, als wir das dann plötzlich konnten.
Ich sagte, überhaupt kein Problem, also zeigen Sie uns mal Ihre Systeme.
Dann haben sie behauptet, sie hätten das nicht.
Da habe ich gesagt, das ist ja ein Fall für die BAföG, wenn sie nicht selber
wissen, was sie hier für Systeme haben.
Ja, ja, ja.
Also macht dann schon ein bisschen Spaß auch.
Stellen die einem nicht auch irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, hunderttausende Anwältinnen
oder so gegenüber, die auf jeden Finger zeigen?
Ja, absolut. Also das ist auch genau Masche. Also es gibt so richtige, wie heißen die nochmal?
Ich glaube Dawnrate-Apps oder sowas. Also richtig für die Banken.
Es gibt so eine Art Durchsuchungsnotfall-Apps, wo dann irgendwie halt die Beratungskanzleien
dann sofort mit 100 Leuten aufschlagen, wenn man einmal so einen Notruf wählt.
Und so war das auch, also da standen sofort irgendwie hunderte drin und ursprünglich,
wie ich das eben auch beobachtet hatte, war es so, dass man ja immer nur mit
so kleinen Gruppen in die Bank ging, also gerade am Anfang waren es fünf,
sechs Mann und wollte ja da Gespräche führen,
stand dann aber 300 Leuten gegenüber und das macht einfach Eindruck,
also da kann man, also die meisten Menschen lassen sich einfach auf so einer
unbewussten Ebene davon,
beeindrucken, zumal die ja sehr arrogant auftreten, schicke Anzüge an,
dicke Uhren an der Hand und Und heißen heute auch alle Professor.
Also das frühe Doktor weiß heute als Professor.
Und Senior irgendwas Englisches dann.
Das sowieso, aber...
Irgend so ein selbstgesielter Titel.
Ja, aber auch, wie gesagt, Wirtschaftsanwälte haben dann auch oft noch so eine
Privatprofessur, was auch immer.
Also jedenfalls ist das so ein bisschen inflationär geworden aus meiner Sicht.
Also auf den Visitenkarten stehen da immer ganz tolle Sachen drauf.
Und zum Beispiel Steuerfahnder, die wirklich auch top ausgebildet werden,
machen eine tolle Ausbildung, die sind dann bestimmt fachlich zehnmal überlegen,
die haben aber kein Studium, also ich will sagen, kein vollwertiges Studium
und das ist irgendwie tief in ihren Köpfen auch drin.
Das fühlen sie irgendwie so unterlegen ganz oft.
Und wenn dann so ein Jurist kommt und tut dann auch so, als hätte er irgendwie
die Weisheit mit Löffeln gefressen.
Und so waren auch die Mechanismen. Also ich habe das auch mal erlebt,
ich war eben dann bei einer anderen Bank, das war diese peinliche Geschichte,
wo wir nicht genügend Speicher hatten, um das Kuhlaufwerk mitzunehmen,
weil ich irgendwie ein bisschen beschäftigt.
Und dann kriegte ich mal mit, bei der anderen Durchsuchungsstelle tat sich so gar nichts.
Also ich habe da mal angerufen und sagte, wie weit seid ihr denn und so und
dann waren die überhaupt nicht weit und dann sagte am Ende des Tages plötzlich
eine Kollegin zu mir, also komm mal schnell rüber, irgendwie die unterschreiben
hier gerade, dass die keine Daten mehr rausgeben müssen. Ich so, was?
Also dann bin ich da sofort drüber gefahren und dann hatte ich so ein Szenario.
Da saßen halt diese fünf Männchen umgeben von, ich würde mal sagen, 200 Anwälten,
die alle, also die saßen zum Teil in so einer U-Form und dann stand noch mal
ein zweites U so hinten an der Wand und die haben einfach, die haben die echt fertig gemacht da und.
Als ich dann da erschien, die konnten mich auch gar nicht so richtig erst zuordnen oder so.
Ich habe gesagt, wie ist denn hier so die Lage? Ja, da habe ich gesagt,
das geht so nicht. Das müssen wir ja anders machen. Wieso sitzen die überhaupt
noch? Wieso sind die nicht da und da und da?
Und dann merkte ich schon, irgendwas tut sich da. Und dann kam aber sofort irgendjemand
mit so einer Professor-Visitenkarte auf mich zu und sagte so,
hier, ich, ich, Professor.
Und dann sagte ich, ja, ja, ist ja gut. Aber was will ich hier machen?
Und das sind so die Momente, da habe ich dann auch gemerkt, da können die gar
nicht mit umgehen. Also normaler funktioniert das ja immer, wenn man dann eine
Visitenkarte auf den Tisch legt und sagt, ja ich Professor, dann denkt man,
oh ja, okay, dann sollen wir beide mal hier hin.
Und weil ich den so total ignoriert habe, war ich jetzt irgendwie etwas seiner
üblichen Mittel beraubt und wir waren noch so in der Selbstfindungsphase und
dann haben wir eben gesagt, jetzt geht da, da, da hin.
Und dann hatten wir die auch schnell überall an den Stellen,
wo die hin wollten und dann waren wir auch in einer Stunde fertig.
Wie kam es denn nun dazu, dass diese Cum-Ex-Fälle überhaupt mal auf ihrem Tisch landeten?
Das ist ja nur etwas, was sozusagen nicht also der Öffentlichkeit natürlich
schon gar nicht bekannt war.
Ich weiß nicht, inwiefern es schon Gerüchte oder allgemeine Weisheiten gegeben
hat, dass es sowas geben muss.
Aber irgendwann muss es ja dann mal irgendwo hervorgesprossen sein.
Wie ist das so in Ihrem Leben passiert?
Ja, also es gab, bevor ich das kriegte, ich kriegte das 2013 in dem ersten Fall,
gab es tatsächlich schon Ermittlungen in Frankfurt, von denen ich aber auch nichts wusste.
Also ich kannte auch die Frankfurter Kollegen, mit denen hatte ich auch mit
Umsatzsteuerkarussellen zusammengearbeitet, wir hatten immer ähnliche Fälle,
aber von Cum-Ex hatte ich ehrlicherweise auch noch nichts gehört.
Und wie so vieles in meinem Leben auch das Zufall.
Eigentlich sollte es eine Kollegin kriegen in dem Fall, aber es war eine Halbpasskraft
und da zeichnete sich schon ab, dass das irgendwie ein dickes Ding ist,
460 Millionen und viel Ausland und so.
So und ja, dann haben wir die Fälle getauscht und ich kriegte den dann eben
und da ich vorher schon Erfahrung gemacht hatte, wie schlecht ausgestattet die Steuerfahndung ist,
habe ich gedacht, das kann ich nicht allein mit denen machen,
ich gucke mal, dass ich irgendwie Polizei mit da reinkriege, möglichst LKA,
also Landeskriminalamt und mit denen hatte ich vorher auch,
also ich war gerade beim Landeskriminalamt mit einem Fall, das war ein Schwarzarbeiter-System
und dann habe ich gleich die Gunst der Stunde genutzt und habe mal rumgefragt,
ob da vielleicht Kapazitäten für diesen Fall frei wären. Und das war auch ein
Glück, das waren die nämlich.
Also es hätte auch sein können, dass sie sagen, wir haben keine Kapazitäten
frei und dann hätte ich was anderes suchen müssen.
Aber es war zufällig, dass sie dann eben auch konnten und dann konnten wir halt
diese großen Auslandsdurchsuchungen machen.
Wie ist das Verhältnis zwischen Staatsanwaltschaft und so einem LKA?
Also müssen die zusammenarbeiten, wollen die? Also was ist das für eine Ebene?
Das LKA kann sich im Grunde genommen die Fälle aussuchen.
Also man hat als natürlichen Ansprechpartner die Polizei, also die in der Fläche
sozusagen, also dann die Kölner Polizei in dem Fall.
Wobei man, wenn man Steuerhinterziehung hat, eigentlich in der Praxis,
die Frage ist, ob das rechtlich wirklich so ist, aber in der Praxis arbeitet
man eigentlich nur mit der Steuerfahndung zusammen.
Und die sind ja nicht so richtig,
wie bisher war das jedenfalls so, nicht so richtig ausgebildet wie Polizeibeamte,
sondern die Finanzverwaltung bildet die so aus, dass die hinterher in die Festsetzungsfinanzämter
gehen oder Betriebsprüfungen machen, also das Besteuerungsverfahren machen.
Die sollen nicht Kriminalität machen. Nur, ich glaube, drei Prozent der Leute,
die ausgebildet werden, gehen überhaupt in den Kriminalitätsbereich rein.
Das heißt, es wird überhaupt kein Schwerpunkt gemacht.
Und das heißt, die sind nicht gerüstet für internationale Kriminalität,
haben keine TKI-Möglichkeiten, tragen keine Waffen und all so Sachen.
Deswegen ist schon gut, die Polizei mit reinzuholen. Man musste sich aber so
ein bisschen verrenken und überlegen, hat man irgendwie noch so ein Delikt,
was vielleicht auch dann die Zuständigkeit der Polizei begründet.
Und in diesem Fall war das so, weil die Anleger sich geschädigt fühlen.
Das war ja auch tatsächlich so, so fing der erste Fall ja an,
dass auch bekannte Menschen wie Maschmeyer und Drogerie Müller,
das ist auch bekannt, da kann ich drüber reden, das war auch in der Presse schon,
dass die eben ihre komplette Einlage
verloren hatten. Also nicht nur keine Rendite, sondern alles war weg.
Genau, die in irgendeinen Fonds investiert haben, der ihnen viel versprochen
hat und dann war die Kohle auf
einmal komplett weg und die haben sich nur gedacht, was geht denn hier?
Richtig. Und das waren jetzt mal so Summen, die die investierten,
die bewegten sich so um 100 Millionen. Also das schmerzt dann schon, wenn das alles weg ist.
Ich schmerze jeden Tag.
Den Schmerz kenne ich. Immer weg.
Ja, jedenfalls, da hatte man Anlegerbetrug mit drin, also ein Delikt für die Polizei.
Und die hatten zusätzlich noch sozusagen einen Mitarbeiter frei,
der jetzt wieder auf der Suche war nach neuen Fällen, aber der sagte auch,
ich komme hier in das Ausruhen, ich könnte also auch noch das und das und das machen.
Zum Glück hat er sich halt für Cum-Ex entschieden und ja, dann hatte ich also
eine gute Ausgangssituation,
weil dann da eine Ermittlungskommission zusammengestellt wurde,
das waren dann so vier oder fünf,
und die hatten vor allen Dingen beim LKA, das Landeskriminalamt,
das ist eben für internationale Kriminalität zuständig, die sind eben darauf
ausgerichtet, also die können große Fälle machen und auch eben internationale.
Die haben zum Beispiel Verbindungsbeamte in verschiedenen Ländern.
Sodass es mit dem Instrumentarium einfach viel besser geht. Und das haben die auch top gemacht.
Also diese Durchsuchung in 14 Ländern, ich habe noch nie gehört,
dass irgendwie eine Staatsanwaltschaft in 14 Ländern durchsucht hat,
aber uns ist das ja auch gelungen. Also das hätte ich selbst nicht gedacht.
Also ich weiß noch, wie die zu mir kamen und sagten irgendwie,
das ist ja alles im Ausland.
Ich sagte, guck mal, wo wir durchsuchen können. Dann sagten die,
das ist alles im Ausland. Wir sind nix in Deutschland, hier ist nur der Schaden
entstanden. Alles andere ist im Ausland.
Ja, und dann waren es halt 14 Länder. und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, lass uns versuchen,
mal gucken, also wie viele Länder mitmachen, man muss die immer bitten,
dass die für einen dann durchsuchen, also wir haben ja staatliche Souveränität,
das heißt, ein deutscher Staat kann jetzt nicht einfach auf fremdem Staatsgebiet
durchsuchen, man muss dann die Behörden bitten,
dass die das für einen machen und da hält sich meistens die Begeisterung in Grenzen,
dann nicht die eigenen Fälle, aber hier war es wirklich so, dass die alle mitgemacht haben,
sogar aus Virgin Islands oder was Besser immer haben wir irgendeinen Zerbeultenkarton bekommen.
Also haben wirklich alle mitgemacht. Das war schon super.
Und damit haben natürlich auch die Täter eigentlich niemals gerechnet,
dass das passieren würde?
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Also wir hatten durchsuchungsbegleitend auch eine Telekommunikationsmaßnahme
laufen. Also wir haben Telefone abgehört.
Und da äußerte sich genau das. Dass sie völlig überrascht waren.
Also ein Satz war so, die sind ja überall.
Und das hat schon Eindruck gemacht. Und das war auch gut. Es war gut,
dass der Staat mal zeigte, es geht.
Also weil sagt ihr immer, ja nichts ist möglich, nichts funktioniert.
Doch, das hat funktioniert.
Und das war mir wichtig, das zu zeigen. Der Staat ist nicht wehrlos,
man kann das schon machen.
Ja.
Ja, was hat Alex Nawalny und Britney Spears und Francis Haugen mit Ihnen gemeinsam? Wissen Sie es?
Bloomberg.
Bloomberg war der Meinung im Jahr 2021, dass sie irgendwie zu den 50 Leuten
gehören, die sozusagen die Ideen, also zu den Leuten gehören,
die die Global Business definiert haben in 20 an 20.
Also scheint schon angekommen zu sein, die Botschaft so in Business-Kreisen,
habe ich so den Eindruck.
Hat sich denn das dann so, ich meine, gut, da waren dann größere Summen schon
mal gleich im Spiel, haben Sie gesagt, zumindest erstmal die 100 Millionen da von den Drogisten.
Wie lange hat das gedauert, bis Ihnen überhaupt klar wurde, was da eigentlich wirklich passiert?
Ja, schon eine Weile. Das erzähle ich auch manchmal so direkt am Anfang.
Als ich das das erste Mal bekam, haben die mir vom Bundeszentralamt für Steuern,
das ist auch eine Behörde, die kein Mensch kennt, das ist auch eine Bundesoberbehörde,
die eigentlich so Datensammlungen macht, aber eben auch für ausländische Steuererstattungen da ist.
Und mit denen haben wir zusammengearbeitet. Die waren da schon länger mit befasst.
Die haben mir das am ersten Tag erklärt mit ganz viel bunten Folien.
Und Da bestellt man die Umsatzsteuer-ID.
Ja.
Ich kenne die.
Das hat er alles von mir gelernt.
Die sind das.
Ja, die sind das, genau. Und die waren auch fachlich echt gut,
also sie haben ja ganz viel bunte Folien gezeigt und ich habe aber kein Wort verstanden.
Und dann habe ich mich aber abends nochmal an den Küchentisch gesetzt und habe
das nochmal aufgezeichnet und so und dachte, ach das ist ja wie ein Umsatzsteuer-Karussell.
Das kannte ich dann wieder. Und deswegen war mir das eigentlich relativ schnell
klar, das ist ja genau das Gleiche wie etwas, was auch schon in der Rechtsprechung,
vorhanden ist, da gab es schon ganz viel Rechtsprechung zu, alles Böse und hohe Aufstrafen und so.
Aber was ich auch anfangs nicht wusste, dass das jetzt nicht nur eine Handvoll
schwarzer Schafe ist, so sah das zunächst aus und das hat natürlich dann auch
die Branche mal so gespiegelt, also das sind ja nur so ein paar,
die das machen, sondern dass das eine Industrie ist.
Und das haben uns Insider gesagt. Also wir haben dann Glück gehabt,
dass wir auch mit Insidern sprechen konnten.
Die waren selber beschuldigt, aber die haben sich dann eben dafür entschlossen,
mit uns zu kooperieren und uns dann eben auch viel zu erzählen über die Branche.
Und wie man immer so schön sagt, unabhängig voneinander befragt,
haben die wirklich die gleichen Mechanismen geschildert und das hat mich auch
ein bisschen vom Stuhl gehauen, ehrlich gesagt, was da dann offenbart wurde,
also was das für Ausmaße hat.
Und dass es so industriell betrieben wird und nach Aussagen der Kronzeugen,
die lange Zeit in den internationalen Investmentbanken gearbeitet haben, manche über zehn Jahre,
die auch sagten, das ist aber hier unsere Arbeitsplatzbeschreibung,
also was sie hier als Straftat bezeichnen.
Das muss so.
Eine sagte, als ich hier anfing, da habe ich so ein Handbuch gekriegt von meiner
Bank, da standen jetzt die zehn besten Tricks drin, also irgendwie Frankreich
gegen UK und so immer, die Steuersysteme ausnutzen, so, so, so und das sollte ich weiterentwickeln.
Also die waren wirklich etwas fassungslos, dass jetzt plötzlich einer sagt,
das ist aber nicht in Ordnung.
Und ja, deswegen, also dieses Ausmaß, der auch sagt, ja das ist das,
womit die halt ihr Geld verdienen.
Also das ist ja konjunkturunabhängig und alle Staaten dieser Welt passen auf
ihre Kassen schlecht auf.
Also das ist in vielen Staaten der Fall, dass die nicht wissen,
was die Banken machen, dass sie auf ihre Steuersysteme nicht gut Acht geben
und deswegen ist das eine super Nummer.
Also das braucht man nicht viel, ist nicht viel Aufwand, ist total unabhängig
von allem, kann man super auch in der Finanzkrise machen, haben sie ja auch.
Da sind wir ja ganz besonders stark geschädigt worden in der Phase,
wo Banken gerettet worden sind, haben die dann bei uns ins Portemonnaie gegriffen,
aber so richtig und damit hatte dann auch keiner ein Problem, komischerweise.
Also von daher ist das, das haben die uns auch geschildert, einer der Haupteinnahmequellen.
Also das ist nicht eine kleine Schicht, die irgendwie Schmuh macht,
sondern das ist eine Branche.
Und das ist natürlich eine bittere Wahrheit. Und also einmal für uns so als Staat.
Und zweitens kann man sich jetzt ungefähr vorstellen, was da für eine Macht hinter steht.
Die lassen sich ja jetzt nicht einfach ihr Geschäftsfeld da wegnehmen,
wenn man so davon auch abhängig ist.
Es ist ja mal ein bisschen schwierig, diese ganzen Tricksereien und Wege,
gerade wenn es mit dem Steuersystem zu tun hat, zu verstehen.
Dieses Cum-Ex-Schema ist ja, ich sag mal so salopp, eine Art wohlterminierter
und wohl abgesprochener Verschiebebano von Aktienbesitz, der letzten Endes dann
versucht, die Behörden Glauben zu machen,
dass irgendwo eine Steuer zu erstatten ist, wo sie eigentlich nicht erstattet werden müsste.
Eine Kapitalertragssteuer in dem Fall, also das, was man quasi auf Aktiengewinne dann zahlen muss.
Und das System wurde ja schon zu Beginn, glaube ich, von manchen Banken angewendet
in kleinem Maße, bis dann eine Person, Hannu Berger,
der selber beim Finanzamt tätig war.
Ist, habe ich gerade seine Stellung nicht mehr ganz...
Betriebsprüfer war der.
Betriebsprüfer, genau, der sich halt auch immer so mit den Banken angelegt hat
und von den Banken auch eher gefürchtet war,
weil er immer alles genau wissen wollte und dann auch denen sozusagen die ganze
Zeit auf die Finger gehauen hat, bis er dann irgendwann mal festgestellt hat,
dass es vielleicht viel lukrativer ist, die Seiten zu wechseln.
Vielleicht wurde er auch von den Banken davon überzeugt, das wissen wir nicht so ganz genau.
Und der hat dann sozusagen dafür gesorgt, dass das eben so ein richtiges Business-Modell wurde.
Das heißt, da wurde hineinberaten und auf einmal war das dann so,
also aus den Schilderungen habe ich so ein bisschen den Eindruck gewonnen,
Auf einmal wussten dann alle, wie das funktioniert und dann wussten aber auch
alle, dass alle anderen das auch machen und dann wollte auch keiner die Bank
sein, die es nicht macht, weil
die anderen machen das ja auch und dann müssen wir das ja auch machen.
Man kriegt so den Eindruck, dass die dann sozusagen vollkommen entfernt davon
sind, was vielleicht irgendwie zulässig ist oder nicht.
Stimmt meine Wahrnehmung?
Ja, also die Rolle von Hanno Berger ist so ein bisschen anders.
Er wurde anfangs so gesehen, also die Frankfurter Kollegen haben ganz früh angefangen
auch mit ihm und haben zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht erkennen können,
weil die Ermittlungen noch nicht so weit vorangeschritten waren,
dass das diesen industriellen Charakter hatte. Das wurde erst später bekannt.
Daher stammt das so ein bisschen, dass man den als Spiritus Rector bezeichnet hat.
Das hat sich aber jetzt so im Laufe der Ermittlungen nicht als ganz richtig
herausgestellt, Sondern was man jetzt weiß ist, dass die internationalen Investmentbanken,
das haben zum Beispiel auch die Kronzäunen gesagt, dass sie das machen seit den 80er Jahren.
Und zwar untereinander.
Also da hatte so ein Hannoverger, der jetzt ganz vermögende Kunden im Gepäck
hatte, denen er auch was Gutes tun wollte, die spielten da keine Rolle.
Sondern das haben die Banken untereinander gemacht.
Auf eigene Rechnung sozusagen. Und haben damit die Kassen der Länder ausgeplündert.
Und der Herr Berger hat das dann demokratisiert und auch neben den Banken noch
den Reichen zugänglich gemacht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also demokratisiert würde ich das nicht nennen.
Das waren ja jetzt nicht so viele.
Die so 100 Millionen haben. Das ist eine spielsoziale Gruppe.
Wie wir heute gelernt haben. Die sind ghettoisiert im Grunewald und haben kaum Kontakt zur Außenwelt.
Und dann fehlen 100 Millionen.
Das schmerzt.
Das korrespondierte mit einer Phase,
wo die Aufmerksamkeit der Finanzbehörden langsam wuchs und dann haben die großen
Banken etwas mehr Raum gelassen, auch für andere Player.
Und einer dieser Player, muss man auch wirklich sagen, einer,
das war nicht der Einzige, war zum Beispiel Hanno Berger, der hatte da von Wind
gekriegt und dachte, ach, das wäre ja was für meine Anleger.
Da, also das ist ja so eine super Rendite, haben die sich natürlich intern noch
überlegt, dass da nur der kleinste Krümmel für die Anleger übrig blieb.
Also die kriegten, das war schon so satte 12 Prozent für drei Monate,
also da fanden die super.
Aber der ganze richtig fette andere Batzen, der ist dann gar nicht an die Anleger
weitergereicht worden. Also das fand Hanno Berger wie andere auch,
die mit ihm zusammengearbeitet haben, natürlich eine super Geschichte.
Also A, war das gut für seine Anleger, B, auch für ihn. Also was bekannt ist,
dass Berger und sein Kollege 100 Millionen an Kickbacks an den Kanzleien vorbeigeschleust haben.
Also 100 Millionen, nur Kickbacks, nicht die Gebühren, die sie eh vereinnahmt haben.
Kickback ist was genau?
Teil der Beute. Teil der Beute.
Also sie haben einen Teil der Beute für sich sozusagen vereinnahmt und haben
den auch, die waren ja früher noch bei Kanzleien angestellt,
an ihren Kanzleien vorbeigeschleust.
Und die Sachen nochmal, diese Zahl, damit einem klar wird, was es da zu verdienen gibt.
Und das ist quasi nur so das, was sie wegschnappen konnten, ohne dass es einer merkt.
Ja, weil sie sich noch obendrauf gegönnt haben, ohne dass es einer sehen durfte.
Weil dann wären die anderen ja vielleicht auch neidisch geworden.
Also deswegen haben die ihren Anlegern natürlich auch nicht...
Deswegen haben die nicht so viel genommen, sondern nur 100 Millionen, dass da keiner das...
Ja, das durfte jedenfalls keiner wissen, weil man sonst ja vielleicht auch,
also wenn man das jetzt Anlegern, professionellen Anlegern mit viel Appetit,
wie das immer so schön heißt, gesagt hätte, dann hätten die ja vielleicht auch was haben wollen.
Und deswegen ist das natürlich verdeckt gemacht worden.
Aber allein diese Summe 100 Millionen, die sagt schon mal vielleicht ein bisschen
was drauf aus, das ist nur der Brocken für die beiden.
So, die ganzen Investmentbanken, die dahinter stehen, natürlich weit mehr daran verdient.
Also nur, dass einem auch mal die Dimensionen klar sind. Also das ist völlig,
also die Zahlen sind alle so groß, die kann man sich gar nicht mal vorstellen im Hirn.
Also wo ich ein bisschen ins Essen gefallen bin, als ich dann noch zur Kenntnis
genommen habe, dass es ja nicht nur die privaten Banken machen,
sondern auch noch Landesbanken dann auch noch mit dabei waren.
Also die ja sozusagen eigentlich im Staatsbesitz sind.
Ja, aber stand halt in der Jobdescription.
Ja, ich meine, es ist natürlich attraktiv, wie gesagt, in Zeiten,
wo man jetzt mit anderen Dingen vielleicht nicht so viel Geld verdienen kann,
vielleicht ist man auch nicht so gut vernetzt wie große internationale amerikanische
Investmentbanken, möchte aber auch gerne oben mitspielen,
möchte sein Managergehalt auch an internationale Klassen angleichen.
Und dann kommt das natürlich wie gerufen.
Und ja, das haben alle Landesbanken gemacht.
Und auch im Zuge von dieser anderen Masche, KumKum, das ist sozusagen Step 1,
man sagt ja immer Doppelerstattung, das sagt man ja, Doppel-Dip heißt das im Englischen.
Also auf einer Aktie wird zweimal gedippt.
Und der erste Dip ist Kumkum.
Also das ist Schritt eins. Die Aktien werden das erste Mal platziert,
damit man sich die Steuer zurückerstatten lassen kann und das fußt darauf,
dass ein Steuerausländer eigentlich die Steuer zahlen müssen, Steuerinländer nicht.
Wir haben hier ganz viele Befreiungsdatbestände im Inland, deswegen werden die
Aktien einmal ins Inland transferiert auf die sogenannten Dividend Holidays.
Also die Phase, Es gibt Präsentationen von Beratungskanzleien,
die Hello und so weiter sagen, die so sagen,
es ist noch wie Karneval, die Dividend-Holiday ist und da kommen die Aktien nach Deutschland,
also wie beim Flipper-Automaten, macht man einen Pling, wird das erste Mal ausgeschüttet
und dann kommen die in den zweiten Rutsch rein, das ist Cum-Ex,
das zweite Mal, wenn ihr das zweite Mal benutzt, das ist der zweite Dip.
Und diesen ersten Dip, den haben auch ganz viele Sparkassen gemacht und Volksbanken,
Raiffeisenbanken, kleine Banken und Sparkassen,
also sind jetzt auch keine internationalen Investmentbanken und das sind also
alles Dimensionen, da kann man sich schon fragen,
Was ist hier eigentlich los?
Kann es sein, dass vielleicht die Zugehörigkeit zu einer Bank an sich schon ein Problem sein kann?
Ja, man könnte über kriminelle Vereinigungen nachdenken.
Da ist man ja an anderer Stelle heutzutage auch ganz schnell dabei,
kriminelle Vereinigungen festzustellen.
Aber das hat ja zum Glück alles ein Ende gefunden, oder?
Nee, leider nicht.
Ach so.
Nee, also das haben auch Grundsätzlich schon öffentliche Aufwandlungen gesagt,
dass sie weitergemacht haben, nicht nur hier in Deutschland, auch international.
Also man hat versucht, der deutsche Gesetzgeber hat versucht,
2011 nochmal die Gesetzeslage anzupassen, das System zu verändern.
Er hat damit den zweiten Vorschlag des Bankenverbandes aufgenommen.
Also der Bankenverband ist ein Lobbyorgan der Banken, hat Gesetzesvorschläge
gemacht. Das machen leider Lobbygruppen oft.
Und der erste Vorschlag ist dann 2007 umgesetzt worden. Das hat uns dann halt
diesen ganzen Cum-Ex, den wir so kennen, beschert.
Und dann hat man 2011 gesagt, das machen wir zwar ganz anders,
aber wir nehmen den anderen Vorschlag.
Und das ist dann halt der geworden. Und ja, das hat leider nichts gestoppt.
Da gibt es auch schon Presseberichterstattung dazu. Also ich darf natürlich
da über Details nicht reden, weil ich immer noch der dienstlichen Verschwiegenheitspflicht unterliege.
Aber es gab schon Presseberichterstattung über Comex-Fälle aus dem Jahr 2016.
Grundsäugen haben das ausgesagt. Und auch diesmal unter dem Stichwort Phantomaktien,
also ADRs sind das. Das sind so Ersatzpapiere für Aktien, die in Amerika gehandelt
werden können, wo unsere deutschen Aktien nicht zugelassen sind.
Da kann man mit Ersatzpapieren hantieren und die sind auch für diese Geschäfte
genutzt worden. Das ist auch so 18, 19 bekannt geworden.
Also von daher sieht man schon die Anhaltspunkte, die allein jetzt öffentlich
bekannt sind, dass es eben nicht gelöst ist, das Problem.
Also es wird nach wie vor...
Steuer doppelt erstattet.
Ja.
Oh.
Ja, da müsste man ja mal was gegen tun.
Oder? Passiert mir irgendwie nie.
Ja, zumal wir auch das Geld gut gebrauchen können. Also es wäre schon prima,
wenn man das mal eintreiben würde, von dem wir wissen.
Ja. Aber dann auch noch was zurückgeben. Also es springt so ein bisschen den Kopf.
Aber wie ist es Ihnen denn jetzt sozusagen dabei ergangen?
Es gab ja dann einen Berufswechsel in diesem Jahr. Ich habe es schon erwähnt.
Wie haben Sie denn die letzte Zeit so erlebt, dass Sie dazu bringen,
mit einer ganz brauchbaren Rente abgesicherte Beamtensituation abzuschließen?
Ja, also die Erfahrungen, die ich bei den Ermittlungen gewonnen habe und das,
was ich gerade geschildert habe, also diese totale Ungleichgewicht zwischen Finanzlobby,
das ist so ein Schlagwort eben
für Banken und Versicherungen und Großunternehmen aus der Finanzbranche.
Also diese Ressourcen, die die auf die Straße bringen und prallen auf einen
Staat, auf staatliche Institutionen, die ausgerechnet an der Stelle eben sehr
schwach aufgestellt werden.
Und deswegen ist es zwar in Köln mal gelungen, viele Kollegen auch zu gewinnen
und da ist eigentlich eine gute Struktur aufgebaut worden.
Auch wie gesagt, dank dieses Justizministers, Herr Biesenbach,
der da eben sehr viel Ressourcen reingepackt hat und auch der anderen Ressource.
Da ist eine gute Struktur geschaffen worden, aber die besteht eben nur da und
die können auch nicht alles lösen. Die können ja nicht weitergehen.
Alles jetzt auf Dauer weitermachen. Das ist eine kleine lokale Staatsanwaltschaft.
Aber üblicherweise werden gute Strukturen doch nachgebaut. Also bei den Banken
hat sich das ja offenbar auch durchgesetzt.
Die haben gesagt, komm, komm, komm, ex-gute Struktur, mach mal noch ein, mach mal ganz viel.
Warum macht der deutsche Staat das nicht und sagt, wir haben eine gute Struktur?
Also es stellt ja, glaube ich, eigentlich niemand in Zweifel,
dass das, was da in Köln passiert ist, eine gute Struktur war.
Sie hat ja Erfolg gebracht. Sie hat auf einmal viel, ich weiß gar nicht,
Also ist dieses Geld zurückgekommen? Nein.
Doch, doch, viel ist zurückgekommen. Also viel ist allein durch die Anklagen
dann auch zurückgefordert worden.
Man kann das im Strafprozess, also mit dem Urteil auch einziehen,
die Summen. Also das ist dann eine Grundlage, dass das Geld zurückkommt.
Gibt es da so eine Hausnummer, wie viel das ungefähr dem deutschen Staat eingespült hat?
Also ich kann das gar nicht genau sagen. Also die Sachen, die wir angeklagt
haben, liegen glaube ich so insgesamt im dreistelligen Millionenbereich.
Aber es kommt noch viel dazu, weil alleine aufgrund der Ermittlungsverfahren
haben dann Banken auch die Anträge zurückgenommen.
Also aufgrund des Ermittlungsdrucks auch. Wir haben Klagen zurückgenommen und
das Bundeszentralamt hat auch viele Bescheide dann erlassen können aufgrund der Ermittlungen.
Das ist eigentlich immer der erste Schritt oder sollte der erste Schritt sein,
dass die Finanzverwaltung tätig wird und Strafrecht soll das nicht ersetzen,
sondern ist noch zusätzlich da.
Also von daher kann ich Ihnen das nicht genau sagen, wie viel das ist,
aber es ist auf jeden Fall mindestens eine dreistellige Millionensumme, wenn nicht mehr.
Und es steht ja auch noch viele aus. Also es sind ja noch viele Fälle in Köln
anhängig. Also die Frage warum, die stellt sich mir auch.
Ich kann mir das nur so erklären, dass das eine Mischung ist zwischen einer
gewissen Uninformiertheit darüber,
aber eben natürlich auch, da kann man sich nichts vormachen,
aufgrund der Einflüsse der Lobby, die zwei Mechanismen am Start haben, einmal Verharmlosung.
Die also oft darauf hinwirken zu sagen, ja das ist ja jetzt eigentlich auch
nur ein Kavaliersdelikt.
Also wenn man hier was machen will mit der Bank und so, dann muss man das machen.
Das sagt man ja oft auch bei Korruption, auch geht gar nicht anders. hast.
Und das sagt man eben bei Steuerhinterziehung auch, ist jetzt nicht so richtig schlimm so.
Und das verfängt ja manchmal auch, weil man denkt, naja, jeder hat schon mal geschummelt.
Und dann denkt man vielleicht, naja, aber das ist ja auch nicht so schlimm,
weil man selber ja vielleicht auch schon mal geschummelt hat bei irgendwas,
beim häuslichen Arbeitszimmer oder was auch immer.
Aber es sind natürlich völlig andere Dimensionen. Hier geht es ja nicht um kleine
Schummeleien, hier geht es um bandenmäßige, organisierte Steuerkriminalität.
Das ist auch eine Bande. Das ist organisierte Kriminalität. Eine ganz andere Dimension.
Und das ist, glaube ich, tatsächlich auch noch gar nicht allen klar,
weil nicht jeder liest ja jetzt so jedes Urteil, was veröffentlicht wird und
viele Urteile werden ja auch gar nicht veröffentlicht, sondern das ist dann
nur so fürs geneigte Fachpublikum.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass das tatsächlich allen staatlichen Stellen klar ist,
zumal die fast nicht miteinander sprechen.
Also ich habe mich in meiner aktiven Zeit immer sehr darum bemüht,
dass ich Kontakt kriegte zu den unterschiedlichen Behörden,
aber da war auch viel Fluktuation und von daher muss man einfach davon ausgehen,
dass jeder so alleine vor sich hinwurschtelt und dann auch vieles gar nicht
so richtig mitkriegt und dann
natürlich auf der anderen Seite aber beschallt wird von einer Branche,
die natürlich sehr gerne sehr früh Kontakt aufnimmt, um Nähe herzustellen.
Und also diese Einflüsse von der Lobby, die scheinen mir eigentlich der zentrale Faktor zu sein.
Das habe ich auch selbst, da darf ich halt nicht drüber sprechen,
aber ich hatte auch selbst Erkenntnisse darüber, wie das in der Praxis so funktioniert
und das ist schon sehr effektiv, weil es ist natürlich auch professionell.
Also es wird professionell gemacht.
Heute haben wir das Lobbyregister, da kann man mal schauen, wie stark die Finanzlobby da abgebildet ist.
Das ist nämlich exakt der stärkste Lobbyakteur, noch vor der Pharmaindustrie,
noch vor der Autoindustrie.
Das ist die Finanzlobby, der stärkste Akteur.
Und die ersten zehn, die abgebildet sind, der Akteure unter der Sablase der
Finanzlobby, die haben ein Budget von über 42 Millionen.
Nur für Lobbying in diesem Bereich, den das Lobbyregister abbildet.
Das bildet nicht alles ab, sondern das bildet nur Lobbying auf Bundestagsebene ab.
Aber zum Beispiel andere Mechanismen, wie zum Beispiel auf die Justiz an anderer
Stelle eingewirkt wird oder auf die Verwaltung eingewirkt wird,
das ist da gar nicht erfasst.
Oder wie viel Literatur zum Beispiel, Auftragsliteratur ist,
um eine Meinung zu prägen, um überlastete Richter oder Staatsanwälte,
die nur fünf Minuten Zeit haben für eine Recherche, die erwartet dann sofort
25 Aufsätze der Branche.
Also wenn man sich über, es ist ja total überlastet überall an allen Stellen
der Behörden, dann guckt man schnell irgendwie in diese Juris zum Beispiel oder
Back Online, gibt es Online-Bibliotheken, wo man dann schnell reinguckt,
um ein bisschen zu recherchieren, wie Rechtslage ist.
Ist, wenn da die Branche aber ihre Rechtsmeinung schon platziert hat und zwar
die ersten 50 Aufsätze sind nur so und dann hat man vielleicht einen von der
Finanzverwaltung und 50 über Steuerrecht.
Das prägt natürlich dann auch die Rechtsprechung und hält vielleicht auch Steuerfahnder
oder Staatsanwälte davon ab, überhaupt zu ermitteln, weil sie denken,
ich habe ja gar keine Chance, das ist ja total wackelig, das Thema.
Also das ist einfach Macht, Macht durch Geld. Und das wirkt natürlich,
wenn man nicht sensibilisiert ist, dann wirkt das verdammt gut.
Und das ist vielleicht auch der Grund dafür, warum wir so schlechte Strukturen in Deutschland haben.
Und diese Aufsätze, die ich dann da finde, die sind von solchen Professoren
mit goldenen Kreditkarten sowieso, Visitenkarten auch noch.
Und die schreiben dann ja übrigens, ich habe mir überlegt, Cum Cum Cum Ex ist legal.
Ja, genau.
Warum, also in anderen Wissenschaften würde ja dann potenziell,
sag ich mal, der Ruf der Publikation leiden.
Ja, wir kennen doch alle die Beratungskanzlei, die mehrfach durchsucht worden
ist, wo einer auch vor Gericht stand, schon verurteilt worden ist.
Den man Namen nicht nennen darf, aber vielleicht kennen wir also eine große
Rechtsanwaltskanzlei.
Ich hatte mal, also die einzige große, die ich kenne, ist Freshfields.
Habe ich auch schon mal gehört in dem Zusammenhang.
Andere kenne ich nicht, aber reden Sie ruhig weiter.
Genau, also eine Große, die auch manche Leute kennen.
Die hat sich ja jetzt, sagen wir mal so, wenn man jetzt draufschaut und schaut,
was haben die eigentlich für eine Auffassung vertreten.
Die haben die Auffassung vertreten als legal.
Die haben das nicht nur publiziert, sondern haben auch im Einzelfall Rechtsgutachten
geschrieben. Und ja, aber schade das jetzt irgendwie.
Also wir beraten immer noch die Regierung in anderen Sachen.
Also auch die Professoren, die schon im Untersuchungsausschuss,
2016 gab es ja einen Untersuchungsausschuss zu Cum-Ex auf Bundesebene,
da ist aufgeflogen, dass Professoren enorm viel Geld dafür bekommen haben,
dass sie eine bestimmte Auffassung vertreten und die auch publiziert haben.
Und diese Professoren, die beraten auch jetzt wieder die Regierung.
Also da fragt man sich natürlich auch, warum? Also gibt es keine anderen,
aber das ist eben Ausfolge der guten Vernetzung.
Finanzwende. Jetzt haben Sie diesen Schritt vollzogen und einfach mal gesagt,
den spannenden Kampf gegen die organisierte Kriminalität, auch wenn Sie das
alle immer so toll finden,
das machen Sie jetzt nicht mehr oder zumindest nicht da in der Oberstaatsanwaltschaft Köln.
Was, also von Finanzämtern haben sicherlich einige schon mal was gehört,
wir haben es ehrlich gesagt, haben wir es schon mal befasst,
ich glaube wir haben uns noch nicht so richtig damit befasst,
aber was sind so jetzt Ihre Ziele, also was sind die Ziele von Finanzwende an sich,
gab es ja auch schon vorher, ist ja nicht neu gegründet worden und wohin soll die Reise gehen?
Also das Thema, was ich auch bei Finanzwende bearbeite, ist das gleiche wie
vorher, nämlich Finanzkriminalität.
Finanzwende selber versteht sich als Gegengewicht zur Finanzlobby und möchte
eben mit den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern zusammen Gegengewicht bilden.
Und zwar bewusst über die Öffentlichkeit, weil die Erfahrung eben die ist,
dass die Finanzlobby im Verborgenen wirkt und zum Beispiel auch bewirkt,
dass die Öffentlichkeit über viele Dinge überhaupt nicht informiert wird und
dann natürlich auch nicht mitdiskutieren kann.
Und da gibt es eigentlich, gab es vorher vor Finanzwende keinen Akteur, der das gemacht hat.
Also im Umweltbereich gibt es ja viele NGOs, die eben die Zivilgesellschaft
auch nutzen, um sagen wir mal darauf hinzuweisen, wie das gerade so aussieht.
Oder es gibt auch andere Bereiche, in denen das.
Kinderrechte oder sowas, aber im Bereich Finanzpolitik gab es gar nichts.
Und das war eben auch die Erfahrung, die Gerhard Schick gemacht hat,
der hat ja nämlich gegründet, die Finanzwende, er war vorher im Bundestag bei
den Grünen und hat dann auch festgestellt,
also hier wirken schon ganz schön starke Lobbykräfte, hier wird ganz schön viel
Nähe hergestellt, so vielen Parlamentarier natürlich auch überlastet sind und
dann auch eben sehr viel beschallt werden.
Und wenn man dem etwas entgegensetzen will, dann hat man jetzt so aus dem Politikbereich
überhaupt keinen, der zu dem Thema arbeitet. Man kann sich auf gar nichts beziehen.
Wenn man für umweltpolitische Sachen arbeitet, kann man sich auf Studien beziehen
und was auch immer. Aber das gab es eben für diesen Bereich nicht.
Und das ist eben der Sinn. Also erstens überhaupt mal diese Debatten auch in
die Öffentlichkeit zu bringen, auch dazu zu arbeiten.
Also Finanzwende schaut sich auch Phänomene wie Finanzialisierung am Mietmarkt an.
Also etwas, was uns ja auch alle betrifft. Wenn da große Finanzinvestoren eben Rendite rausziehen,
dann steigen für uns die Mieten und das ist sehr unangenehm,
das betrifft uns alle und das sind Themen, wo Finanzwende arbeitet oder erstmal
sich das Phänomen anschaut, informiert und dann auch öffentliche Debatten anstößt.
Es hat eben auch einen aktivistischen Zug.
Es geht nicht nur darum, dass man Leute berät und die irgendwie zum Umdenken
bringt, sondern es geht auch ganz bewusst, dass es sich an die Öffentlichkeit
wendet, um diese auch zu mobilisieren.
Was aber natürlich auch nur funktioniert, wenn diese Themen überhaupt mal in
der Öffentlichkeit stattfinden.
Und ich selber kann das gut verstehen, dass finanzpolitische Themen total weit
weg sind von der Wirklichkeit eines jeden Menschen, waren die auch lange in
meinem Leben. Aber ich habe eben auch erfahren, was passiert,
wenn man sich nicht drum kümmert.
Das Thema hatten wir gerade auch schon. Man lebt so in seiner Blasung,
kriegt vieles gar nicht mit und wundert sich, dass Dinge nicht funktionieren.
Dass unsere Freibäder alle geschlossen sind, dass die Kinder nicht mehr schwimmen
lernen können, weil wir keine Schwimmbäder mehr haben, dass die Mieten steigen,
dass Pflegeheime pleiten gehen.
Das sehen wir alles und wir wissen nicht, woran es liegt.
Ich habe gehört, die Ausländer sind schuld.
Das wird uns dann erzählt.
Ja, genau.
Und dann ist es natürlich schon wichtig und es ist mir auch wichtig,
dass diese Informationen überhaupt mal die Öffentlichkeit erreichen und dass
man dann auch zum Mitmachen aufgefordert wird.
Das ist eben auch unser Ansatz, zum Beispiel über Petitionen oder über offene
Briefe oder ich versuche auch viel mit Interviews auch Journalisten mit einzubeziehen.
Ich finde, das ist auch eine wichtige Stellschraube, denn auch Journalisten,
ja, den gibt es ja so wie uns allen, also es sind einfach Fachthemen und woher
soll man immer diese ganze Fachtermin,
Terminologie wissen und sich da so einarbeiten und man, gleiches Phänomen,
man wird von der anderen Seite ordentlich beschallt und dann steht man da.
Also auch Journalisten sozusagen in die Lage zu versetzen, sich selbst eine
Meinung zu bilden und auch,
sie sozusagen zu ermächtigen, also sich auch selbstbewusster in dieser Thematik
zu fühlen, um dann eben auch darüber zu berichten und eben den anderen Argumenten,
die da so fliert werden aus dem politischen Raum, da auch was entgegenzusetzen.
Ein hehres Ziel.
Ja, ich denke, ich spreche hier für alle, wenn ich Ihnen dabei viel Kraft und viel Erfolg wünsche.
Da so ein Finanz-Greenpeace an den Start zu kriegen.
Vielleicht seilen Sie sich ja auch mal von irgendeinem Finanzamt ab oder so.
Das wäre vielleicht auch noch mal eine Aktion.
Auch ganz ehrlich, ich habe auch die Erfahrung gemacht, es lohnt sich einfach
mal mit diesen Thematiken auseinanderzusetzen, weil, ja, da läuft einfach viel
schief und viel ist einfach nur ein Mangel an Aufmerksamkeit und Verständnis
und das lässt sich eigentlich auch herstellen.
War ja auch mit der Umwelt mal ähnlich, das hat man ja auch alles so wegignoriert
und warum sollte man das tun?
Ja, vielen Dank, dass Sie bei uns waren.
Ihr Applaus, ganz toll.
Dankeschön.
Steht auf.
Vielen, vielen Dank.
Ich hätte die Kettnis genommen.
Wenn ich da auch aufstehe.
So,
und wir beide? Linus? Was machen wir jetzt?
Ich mache jetzt noch was ganz Schwieriges, Tim. Das ist ganz schwierig,
weil es fällt mir schwer, darüber zu reden und dir schwer, dir das anzuhören, weil es geht um Blut.
Es gibt gerade relativ wenig Blutkonserven und das kann man spenden,
beim Roten Kreuz zum Beispiel und dann kriegen das Leute,
die es brauchen und dass ich heute hier sitzen kann,
hängt unter anderem auch damit zu tun, dass Menschen das gemacht haben.
Und deswegen würde ich mich freuen, wenn ihr darüber nachdenkt,
ob ihr Blut spenden wollt. Tim, du bist ausgeschlossen. Ich weiß,
dass du das nicht so gut über dich bringst.
Aber überlegt mal, kostet nichts. Man kriegt eine wunderschöne hässliche Tüte
oder so einen Kugelschreiber oder einen Regenschirm vom Deutschen Roten Kreuz.
Und ein sehr gutes Gefühl, wenn man das gemacht hat. Und vor allem,
wenn man das regelmäßig macht. Das wollte ich euch noch gerne ans Herz legen. Vielen Dank.
Ja, das war es eigentlich jetzt, was wir so hatten.
Ich hoffe, ihr wart mit der Auswahl unserer Gäste ganz zufrieden. Wir waren es.
Ich will die Gelegenheit auch nochmal nutzen und verspreche auch sicherlich
für Linus, mich irgendwie bei euch zu bedanken, alle, die ihr hier seid und
alle, die auch sonst so zuhören.
Wir haben jetzt schon wieder vergessen, zwölf Jahre oder was? Keine Ahnung.
13? 2011 irgendwann angefangen.
Auf jeden Fall, wir machen es schon lange, wir machen es gerne.
Wir machen es vor allem gerne, weil wir so herzliches Feedback bekommen,
weil wir so viel Unterstützung auch von euch bekommen in jeder Form.
Gute Tipps und alles Mögliche.
Und es ist uns eine Freude und eine Ehre, das auch so machen zu können.
Und das verträgt ein herzliches Dankeschön und das spreche ich hiermit aus.
Vielen Dank. Vielen Dank.
Und dann glaube ich, gibt es einen Menschen, der die ganze Zeit auf der Bühne
war für euch, der auch noch einen Applaus braucht.
Das ist der Roland, der die ganze Zeit für euch gezeichnet hat. Roland Brückner.
Vielen Dank.
Genau. Dann noch vielen Dank an unsere Freunde, die uns hier mit T-Shirts und
allem und dem Einlass und so weiter geholfen haben.
Vielen Dank auch an die Urania für die tolle Zusammenarbeit.
Hat super funktioniert.
Ich sag, das war's. Vielen Dank. Das war Logbuch Netzpolitik 500.
Danke, dass ihr gekommen seid. Bis bald. Applaus.